21 je suis saisie de six amendements de
rétablissement de l'article faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 120 monsieur rythm and
soyez merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues cet
amendement n'est pas un plaidoyer contre
l'instruction en famille je n'ai
d'ailleurs personnellement aucun grief
contre le principe de l'instruction aux
familles il est d'ailleurs bien possible
que ce cadre peut dans certains cas
permettre un meilleur apprentissage et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
nécessaire d'y avoir des autorisations
large qui permette de préserver la
liberté d'enseignement des parents
l'état de santé de l'enfant ou son
handicap
la pratique d'activités sportives ou
artistiques intensive l'itinérance de la
famille williams en géographique mais
également l'existence d'une situation
propre à l'enfant motivant le projet
éducatif non le sujet tout autre le
sujet est celui de l'enfance et du rôle
structurant de l'école
au cours de cette période de la vie
l'enfance n'est-elle pas celle de la
découverte des autres de la
confrontation avec des camarades
différent de ses frères et soeurs sur
tous les plans
on parle de pma sans peine mais quid de
l'enfant son camarade une soeur ou un
frère ne remplaceront pas le meilleur
ami qui nous fascine parce que différent
de soi lançant ce n'était pas ce moment
où l'on se confronte à une autorité à
une façon de penser différente de son
père ou de sa mère
qui de mieux qu'un instituteur ou un
professeur pour remplir ce rôle
d'aucuns regrettent le rôle de la
cohésion sociale qu'avait le service
militaire mais alors comment accepter de
zapper l'école qui est le lieu où l'on
se frotte aux autres
où l'on apprend les choses de la vie ses
règles ses frustrations aussi l'école et
l'apprentissage de la vie en société
or la société n'est pas la communauté
on s'y socialise plus qu'en demeurant
dans le cercle familial
l'école offre cet accès à une mixité
sociale improvisé à une diversité non
choisi creuset de la découverte de la
différence de l'apprentissage de la vie
en société
l'école permet à l'enfant de bénéficier
d'une instruction partager et ouverte
sur le monde
remettre l'école républicaine et son
importance capitale comme base au coeur
des débats et le but de cet amendement
et le sénat ne peut faire l'économie
d'un tel débat en balayant d'un revers
de main cet article 21 merci
l'amendement 103 monsieur manille merci
la présidente monsieur mélismes chaque
oeil notre amendement tend à rétablir
l'article 21 qui a été supprimée lors de
l'examen par la commission de la culture
et dans sept cantons de le rétablir dans
une version qui soit proche de celle qui
est issue des débats de l'assemblée
nationale le groupe socialiste est
favorable à la mise en place d'une
autorisation préalable l'instruction en
famille ce mode de scolarisation certes
marginal est néanmoins recrudescence
aujourd'hui depuis l'abaissement de
l'âge de l'instruction obligatoire à 3
ans
trente cinq mille enfants un sommet en
famille en 2018 on en serait aujourd'hui
à 50 milles en 2020 nous avons donc là
une pente qui est significative notre
argument majeur mais cela a été dit tout
à l'heure pour notre collègue grille et
man c'est que l'instruction dans la
famille ne favorise pas la socialisation
de l'enfant ne favorise pas
l'apprentissage de l'associé de la
citoyenneté
mais dès favorise grandement la mixité
sociale
seule la scolarisation est garante de
ses apprentissages qui ne sont pas
anecdotiques mais fondamentaux les
contrôles actuels de ce mode
d'instruction pour le moment soumis à
simple déclaration préalable sont tout à
fait aléatoire ici ou là
plus ou moins mal effectué le dispositif
prévoyant non l'interdiction de
l'instruction en famille comme l'avait
initialement envisagé de président en
afrique mais son statut dérogatoire à
celui désormais de droit commun la
sionisation nous convient je les dis la
règle pour nous c'est l'instruction dans
la sonorisation à l'école de la
république dans l'intérêt premier de
l'enfant nous tenons aussi beaucoup à la
présentation d'un projet pédagogique
pour ces familles qui conserveront
l'instruction à domicile et nous tenons
aussi à la vérification des capacités
des parents et de la dispense de
l'enseignement majoritairement en langue
française ce renforcement des contrôles
d'oeuvre est à vos sérieux riz permettre
de contrôler effectivement mieux
l'ensemble des familles concernées qui
resterait dans une situation dérogatoire
par par alice mme des formes je
proposerai tout à l'heure un amendement
qui soumettra l'ouverture des écoles
privées hors contrat autorisation
préalable au sinistre merci alors dans
cette discussion commune j'ai deux
amendements identiques le 619 madame
avait madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues les conséquences de
l'équipe idée me et des mesures
restrictives qu'elle rend encore
nécessaire rappelle le rôle
incontournable de la scolarisation
notamment pour l'intégration sociale et
le bien-être de nos enfants par les
valeurs qu'elle véhicule l'école est
aussi le socle de notre république
laïque
en deux ans le nombre d'instruments
famille a augmenté de plus de 50%
toutes les classes d'âge sont sont
concernés la tendance est structurel
c'est pourquoi il nous apparaît
aujourd'hui nécessaire de mieux encadrer
l'instruction en famille et ce dans
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
que nous apprennent les rapports des
contrôles pédagogique que le droit à
l'instruction n'est pas toujours
garantie de façon suffisante que
l'instruction en famille est de plus en
plus contourner que c'était loigne mans
peut donner lieu
et dérives sectaires communautaire ou
alors à la mise en danger des enfants
si les signalements transmis certains
rôles elle des comportements très
préoccupant est ce aussi un enjeu elle
et c'est aussi un enjeu de santé
publique dépistage des troubles
vérification du respect des obligations
vaccinales éducation avec à
l'alimentation et à la sexualité
en l'état actuel du droit c'est au maire
qu'il appartient de faire connaître aux
d'athènes certains manquements dans la
pratique les contrôles a posteriori ne
permettent pas de mettre fin à la
situation des enfants fantômes l'article
21 celui issu des travaux de l'assemblée
nationale propose est de substituer au
régime actuel
un régime d'autorisation préalable de
l'instruction en famille limitant son
recours à quatre motifs cette
disposition dont nous regrettons la
suppression en commission vient
d'ailleurs en quelque sorte compléter
une autre mesure qui a été voté par le
parlement
il s'agit de l'instruction obligatoire à
3 ans il est donc proposé de rétablir la
version avant commission merci merci
l'amendement 640 monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre c'est à vous pardon
excusez moi je n'avais pas bien entendu
merci mme la présidente
le alors évidemment ce débat nous
l'avons eue en commission et chacun on
connaît les termes je ne vais pas faire
un long discours
l'instruction à domicile n'est pas en
instruction en famille comme on dit
n'est pas en procès au travers de ce
projet de loi je dirais même tout au
contraire comme beaucoup de liberté elle
se trouve précisé par la loi et elle a
besoin d'être précisée pour justement
avoir une assise plus solide
je ne referai pas l'histoire
constitutionnelle de la liberté
d'instruction en famille et ni de la
liberté d'enseignement néanmoins comme
vous le savez lorsque le juge
constitutionnel en 1977 consacré la
liberté d'enseignement
il le fait en se référant aux principes
fondamentaux reconnus par la république
qu'il va trouver dans une loi de
finances 2009 130
chacun verra bien quelle est donc
postérieur et à 1905 et au loi de 1881
instaurant l'école et qui sont en fait
les premières lois sur la laïcité au
travers de de l'école de la république
cette histoire bien particulière fait
que si l'on se réfère aux travaux
législatifs des années 1880 on voit bien
que l'instruction en famille n'est pas
du tout partie prenante de la nouvelle
logique éducative installé par les lois
de la république
bien au contraire elle apparaît comme
une sorte de suite un peu historique de
ce qui se passait avant notamment le
précepte aura dans les familles les plus
aisées
cette histoire est évidemment à un des
aspects de la question mais elle est
importante
à partir du moment où des questions
constitutionnelles sont sont soulevés et
je dirais des questions philosophiques
alors les choses ont parfois été un peu
caricaturée depuis que ce débat a lieu
depuis plusieurs mois nous n'avons
jamais eu
l'objectif d'en finir avec l'instruction
en famille pour autant c'est ce que font
certains pays l'allemagne la suède
l'espagne qui ne sont pas considérées
comme anti démocratiques ont bien
interdits l'instruction en famille sans
être censuré pour cela par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
pourtant donne des signaux qui sont
cousins je dirais
des signaux donnés par notre conseil
constitutionnel il ya donc autour du
statut de l'instruction en famille des
questions légitimement posée
je ne doute pas d'ailleurs que nous
aurons une jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel le moment venu qui nous
permettra d'avoir ce cadrage nous
aurions pu avoir cette position que je
qualifierais à l'allemande ou à la
suédoise ou à l'espagnol nous n'avons
pas eu nous n'avons pas eue d'avoir ce
que nous avons été en position de
dialogue
nous l'avons été évidemment comme comme
il se doit avec le conseil d'état ce qui
nous a conduits là déjà deux premières
évolutions par rapport au projet initial
nous l'avons été par rapport au monde
des familles qui se sont beaucoup
mobilisés on l'a écouté compris
d'ailleurs un certain nombre d'arguments
de façon à élargir le nombre déception
que nous avions prévu initialement donc
pas seulement les les enfants qui ont
besoin de l'enseignement famille du fait
de leurs problèmes de santé mais aussi
d'autres catégories vous les connaissez
et cet élargissement des exceptions a
bien indiqué que ce que nous visions
c'était l'instruction en famille des
voiliers c'est à dire celle qui sert
tout simplement à ce qu'on appelle
maintenant le séparatisme un séparatisme
qui existent bel et bien que nous
n'avons pas inventé et kiwis en effet
prend la figure de l'instruction en
famille à certains moments et nous
savons qu'il y a de la bonne et de la
mauvaise instructions aux familles alors
nous serions encore si nous ne faisions
pas la distinction entre les deux mais
seront encore ce qui aussi ne font pas
cette distinction en faisant semblant de
ne pas voir les problèmes qui existent
je le rappelle plus de la moitié des
enfants que nous trouvons dans les
structures que nous démantelons leçon
sous couvert de l'instruction en famille
et nous devrions rester à ne rien faire
nous devrions rester à ne rien faire
que pensent ceux qui tous les jours
critiques le gouvernement en disant que
nous ne faisons pas assez contre le
radicalisme islamiste et qui d'un seul
coup sur ce sujet devienne comme aveugle
aux problèmes réels qui se posent sur le
terrain fait des propositions mais vous
ne pouvez pas dire que l'instruction en
famille ne pose aucun problème oui elle
pose un problème
et elle pose en train de séparatisme pas
seulement au titre du radicalisme
islamiste au titre par exemple des
sectes le tout autre phénomène et je les
dis dans mon introduction à la
présentation de cette loi cette loi elle
ne défend pas seulement les valeurs de
la république
elle défend les droits de l'enfant est
en réalité c'est la même chose quand on
défend les valeurs dollar
public on défend les droits de l'enfant
et vice versa alors il est assez facile
gel est malheureusement déjà entendu de
faire un peu de démagogie avec tout cela
et de faire comme si on ne voyait pas
les problèmes
chacun prend ses responsabilités dans ce
genre de situation et je n'ignore pas ce
que l'on m'annonce comme vote dans cette
haute assemblée
mais que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités dans les débats futurs
qu'il aura sur le quai sur la question
parce que c'est facile d'être contre les
enjeux de séparatisme contre le
séparatisme ça qui se manifeste dans nos
sociétés dans des discours généraux et
dès qu'il faut avoir un peu de courage
politique pour aller droit au but sur
les phénomènes que l'on voit ne pas le
prendre
j'ai entendu ce que j'ai entendu chacun
prendra ses responsabilités
vous n'êtes pas obligé de vous sentir
concernés par ce que j'ai à me dire vous
levez vous le vous le montrerai dans vos
dans vos propos ce qui est très
important c'est que chacun en conscience
regarde le phénomène et j'adhère ce qui
a été dit par la sénatrice et aussi
monsieur le sénateur à l'instant c'est à
dire que oui se joue dans l'école de la
république
quelque chose d'essentiel dans l'école
en général dans l'école en général
quelque chose d'essentiel ce qui se joue
dans la classe dans la cour de
récréation dans la sociabilité
parce que l'école ne transmet pas
seulement des savoirs elle transmet
aussi des valeurs alors nous sommes très
respectueux des familles qui ont choisi
l'instruction en famille pour de bonnes
raisons
et elles n'ont rien à craindre de la loi
qui va arriver et c'est même dommage de
dépenser parfois de l'énergie pour
quelque chose qui ne fera pas de tort à
ceux qui n'ont aucune raison de craindre
cette loi en revanche oui on a qui ont
tout lieu de croire de craindre cette
cette loi c'est ce qui aujourd'hui
développe des structures clandestines en
utilisant l'instruction en famille c'est
les familles salafistes qui ont utilisé
cela pour qui utilisons encore cela
aujourd'hui pour écarter leurs enfants
et notamment leur fille de l'instruction
publique
alors oui c'est ce que nous voulons au
travers de cette loi l'intention du
législateur
eh bien nous y participons par les
propos que nous tenons
c'est ce que je fais maintenant elle est
très claire elle guidera aussi ce que
fera l'éducation nationale une fois que
cette loi sera adopté parce que l'enjeu
n'est pas seulement de vote législatif
il est aussi d'avoir une administration
organisé pour réussir le contrôle de
l'instruction en famille c'était aussi
quelque chose de trop faible dans notre
système éducatif depuis un siècle et
demi
il faut nous seront donc organisées
pour tout simplement nous assurer que
l'instruction en famille se passe bien
donc nous n'allons pas mettre fin à
l'instruction en famille en revanche
nous allons lui donner un cadre plus net
et ce cadre plus net permettra de
renforcer la république et de renforcer
les droits de l'enfant si alors
l'amendement 526 madame brulin vous
faites peut-être le 527 aussi merci
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
moi je considère et comme beaucoup
d'autres ici que la liberté n'est pas et
ne doit pas être contradictoire avec les
droits de l'enfant à une instruction de
qualité
est ce que c'est ce qui guidera nos
propres choix mais avec cet amendement
qui est sur un sujet un petit peu
différent nous souhaitons débattre de
l'instruction en famille qu'on pourrait
qualifier de subi ou de contrainte parce
qu'il y a des cas où cette possibilité
apparaît comme un genre de dernier
recours pour des parents désemparés face
au mal être de leurs enfants ou parce
que tous les moyens ne sont pas mis en
place dans l'école pour les accueillir
comme il se doit
je pense par exemple aux enfants qui ne
ne bénéficie pas d'un as hb ou du navet
sachent ce qu'ils peuvent dans bien des
cas conduire à ce que les familles
recourent à l'instruction en famille et
donc avec cet amendement on propose
qu'un temps des changes entre les
parents les services académiques et
municipaux soient mis en oeuvre en cas
de demande d'instruction en famille et
que ce temps des changes permettent
notamment aux familles de se voir
proposer l'inscription de leurs enfants
dans une autre école c'est à dire que
c'est peut-être proposer un autre choix
avant de recourir à l'instruction en
famille cela permettrait à notre sens
également aux équipes municipales
d'avoir une meilleure visibilité des
effectifs dans les communes ce qui est
très important dans l'élaboration des
mesures de carte scolaire puisque bien
souvent vous le savez monsieur le
ministre
une ouverture une fermeture de classe
peut se jouer à un élève près et enfin
cette possibilité d'inscription dans une
nouvelle école permettrait à notre sens
également de garantir à chaque enfant
que les digues l'éducation nationale lui
offre des conditions d'apprentissage les
meilleures possibles mais que ça c'était
et je continue madame la présidente pour
le
526 et le 527 demande que des moyens
supplémentaires soit mis en oeuvre pour
que les inspecteurs de l'éducation
nationale puisse effectuer leur mission
de contrôle de l'instruction en famille
avec tous les outils possibles
je rappelle que les familles sont
actuellement soumises à un contrôle
annuel
l'idée étant de vérifier que
l'instruction des enfants répondent bien
aux attentes des savoirs dit
fondamentaux et aux liens qui sont
évidemment on doit fait être fait avec
les programmes et nous pensons que grâce
à une formation adaptée aux enjeux de
l'instruction en famille les inspecteurs
sauront mieux appréhender les situations
diverses qui relève de cette instruction
en famille ils sauraient ils sauront
ainsi mieux déceler les éventuels
manquements ou mieux répondre aux
demandes des familles toujours dans
l'objectif d'offrir à chaque enfant une
instruction de la plus grande qualité
possible je vous remercie
merci l'avis de la commission monsieur
rapporteur sur ces amendements
oui ou non la présence merci les les
amendements 120-103 619 640 partagent
une forme un tout petit peu différente
partagent un but commun rétablir le
régime d'autorisation pour l'instruction
en famille la modification du régime de
déclaration en régime d'autorisation
fait couler beaucoup d'encre salive
aussi et l'encadrement du recours à
l'ios remets en cause de notre point de
vue le principe de la liberté
d'enseignement qui repose sur les
piliers depuis plus de que nous
connaissons depuis plus de 140 ans
l'école publique
l'école privée sous ou hors contrat et
l'instruction en famille surtout et en
tant qu' en tant que rapporteur je
m'interroge sur le lien véritable entre
séparatisme et instruction en famille le
ministère n'a mené où vous le savez
aucune étude véritable sur ses enfants
je me l'étude d'impact qui est associé à
ce projet de loi est quand même
particulièrement lacunaire et au cours
de mes auditions aucun document
attestant de ce lien
a été présentée nous l'avons évoqué je
n'ai aucun document de ce type
à ma connaissance la commission lors de
l'examen de précédents textes à accepter
une modernisation du cadre du recours à
l'instruction en famille ce qui n'est
pas incompatible et j'ai encore le
ministre la naïveté de penser que nous
pouvons encore vous convaincre c'est la
bonne démarche
il permet d'atteindre un équilibre entre
liberté d'enseignement et droit à
l'instruction dans le cadre de la
protection de l'enfant bien évidemment
l'article matin issue des travaux de
l'assemblée nationale ne répond pas à ce
principe principe de proportionnalité
les limites qu'ils apportent à la
possibilité de recourir à l'instruction
en famille sont particulièrement
importantes alors même que les outils
juridiques existants pour contrôler
l'instruction en famille ne sont pas
pleinement utilisés il y a eu aucune
évaluation de ces règles de ce nouvelles
mesures législatives introduites dans la
loi pour une école de la confiance par
exemple le lien entre séparatisme et
instructions aux familles qui sous-tend
la jeunesse de cet article 21 vient du
constat empirique du constat empirique
de la présence d'enfants déclaré en
instruction en famille dans des écoles
clandestines
je les dis dans la discussion générale
que cinq ou six ça consistait 1
on a un amalgame assez malhonnête donc
des constats qui ont été faits en 2019
et 2020 créant donc cet amalgame diffusé
d'ailleurs auprès assez largement auprès
de l'opinion publique sur les écoles de
fait monsieur le ministre la commission
soutient le gouvernement l a maintenue
par exemple la possibilité de la
fermeture administrative de cellules le
régime d'autorisation avec un délai de
deux mois dont dispose l'administration
pour traiter la demande semble également
méconnaître une réalité entre 40 et 50 %
des enfants sont instruits en famille -
danon et toutes les demandes ne se font
pas au moment de la rentrée scolaire
enfin nous pouvons nous interroger sur
la capacité des services déconcentrés de
l'éducation nationale pour traiter
chaque année quelques 50 à 60 mille
demandes d'autorisation qui lui
incomberait les moyens à s'immobiliser
pour être utilisée pour s'assurer du
contrôle annuel effective de l'ensemble
des enfants instruits en famille
pour répondre à certains de mes
collègues
y'a pas de soucis pour avoir un débat
sur ce sujet depuis 1882 et les lois
ferry bien évidemment notre société a
connu des changements profonds à
commencer par la séparation de l'église
et de l'état 23 ans plus tard c'est pas
neutre je conçois donc qu'il faille
apporté quelques compléments aux régimes
existants c'est ce que nous avons fait
avec les articles 21 bis et suivants
adopté par la commission culture tout en
préservant le régime déclaratif et je me
permets de reprendre vos propres mots
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit il
n'a pas été question d'en finir avec
l'instruction en famille ce ne sont pas
les mots du président de la république
aux mureaux la volonté c'était d'en
finir avec l'instruction en famille
faire la distinction entre bonnes et
mauvaises f
nous y sommes tout disposés et là aussi
les articles 21 bis et suivants font
oeuvre de de marche en avant si je puis
me permettre
pour aller traquer les fraudeurs et ceux
qui utilisent le f à des fins détournées
pour toutes ces raisons l'avis de la
commission est défavorable sur les
amendements visant à rétablir une forme
ou une autre le régime d'autorisation
donc c'est un avis défavorable pour les
abonnements 120-103 619 et 640
l'amendement 526 qui met à qui place qui
met en place par dans un entretien
obligatoire avec le chef d'établissement
lorsque une famille décide en cours
d'année de déscolariser leçons enfants
on constate dans les faits qu'il ya un
dialogue entre les familles et là les
responsables de l'établissement scolaire
avant la déscolarisation
donc c'est un avis défavorable et la vie
est en revanche favorable pour
l'amendement 527 pour le contrôle des
enfants instruits en famille il me
semble que c'est une bonne idée que
sinon d'avoir des inspecteurs totalement
dédié à la au contrôle de l'instruction
en famille au moins qu'ils y soient
particulièrement sensibilisés et formés
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre sur ces amendements
oui merci monsieur le rapporteur super
et entendu vos arguments le il ya
plusieurs présupposés dans ce que vous
avez dit le premier présupposés ce
serait que un régime déclaratif serait
plus conforme aux libertés qu un régime
d'autorisation c'est déjà un point de
divergence entre nous et je ne changerai
pas d'avis sur sur cette question le
régime d'autorisation et cela commande
ensuite l'ensemble des autres arguments
c'est celui qui nous permet d'avoir une
approche a priori et cette approche a
priori c'est ce qui permet de plus
protéger les enfants lorsqu'on a une
approche a posteriori ça signifie que
l'on accepte que éventuellement pendant
plusieurs mois un enfant se trouvent
dans une situation qui n'est pas
conforme à ses droits et quand bien même
il y en aurait peu et malheureusement il
n'y en a pas peu mais quand bien même il
y en aurait peu cette protection de
l'enfant justifient que nous ayons une
vision a priori de ce que nous voulons
faire en matière de contrôle de
l'instruction en famille alors bien
entendu je peux être d'accord avec bien
des choses que vous avez dit à commencer
par notre capacité à personnaliser
davantage la proche est justement de ce
fait à être plus protecteur de l'enfant
alors cela fait évidemment dire cela
fait tomber l'ensemble de votre contre
proposition vous le comprenez bien
puisque je considère que le texte tel
qu'il ressort de l'assemblée nous permet
à la fois d'être sur un régime
d'autorisation de prévoir des exceptions
et de recouvrir l'ensemble des
possibilités que vous cherchez à
réintroduire mais vous cherchez les
réintroduire parce que d'une certaine
façon si vous me permettez c'est un
hommage que vous rendez au texte que
vous avez par ailleurs amende et puisque
vous dites qu'en fait il a toute une
série de qualité que vous voulez
rétablir sous une forme différente
alors je vous dis garder les qualités
dans la forme initiale et nous pourrons
justement nous entendre comme vous le
souhaitiez donc avis défavorable merci
alors pour explication de vote même
delattre la présidente
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'instruction en famille est inscrite
dans le droit français depuis la loi de
jules ferry de 1882 elle est contrôlée
et encadrée par l'état
un contrôle et un encadrement qu'il faut
renforcer et c'est l'objet des nombreux
amendements que porteront que portera le
rds
le conseil d'état s'est prononcé en sa
faveur le conseil constitutionnel l'a
reconnu comme une liberté à valeur
constitutionnelle
l homme ne vous posez pas de problème
monsieur le ministre quand nous vous
avons auditionné dans le cadre de la
commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste
il ne faut donc pas lui couper la tête
mais il faut essayer de trouver le juste
milieu et je ne voudrais pas qu'on reste
sur des images d'epinal j'ai entendu un
collègue
j'avais l'impression que l'instruction
en famille c'est des enfants qui reste
24 heures sur 24 chez eux les outils
pédagogiques ont fort heureusement
évolué il ya des temps de regroupement
aujourd'hui il faut dépasser ses idées
reçues il faut que nous arrivions dans
cet hémicycle à trouver le juste milieu
parce que oui il y a des dévoiements
c'est certain l'instruction en famille
il faut les combattre mais ne pas
condamner
a priori tout le monde sait ce que je
vous disais dans ma déclaration générale
en adoptant l'article 21 tel que vous
l'avez rédigé vous priver de liberté une
partie une grande partie des familles
qui vivent cette instruction en famille
normalement et vous faites le jeu des
islamistes
un combat qu'ils vont gagner si vous
persistez dans cet article 21 tels que
vous souhaitez le voir revenir tel que
vous l'aviez rédigé originellement dans
ce jeu ce milieu je pense qu'il y a à
travailler et ce sera le sens des
amendements que nous vous présenterons
après certains articles pour ma part et
une grande majorité du rds ne voteront
pas ne votera pas le rétablissement de
cet article 21 merci
monsieur ouzoulias ce merci la
présidente monsieur le ministre mais mes
chers collègues il existe une relation
ancienne entre la république et la
nécessité d'une instruction nationale
qui garantissent les droits des enfants
dans son projet de constitution en 1793
condorcet l'exprimer ainsi l'instruction
élémentaire et le besoin de tous et la
société la doit également à tous ses
membres
c'est ce qui a été repris dans la
constitution de 1848 que je vous cite
l'enseignement est libre la liberté
s'exerce selon les conditions de
capacité et de moralité déterminé par
les lois et sous la surveillance de
l'état
cette surveillance s'étend à tous les
établissements d'éducation et sans
aucune exception
ferdinand buisson auquel nous devons le
mot laïcité et qui est l'un des
promoteurs de la loi de 1905 le disait
encore que justement je le cite nous ne
pouvons songer à reconnaître pour un
futur membre de la société la liberté de
se passer d'enseignement ni pour ses
parents celle de l'en priver
nous ne songeront pas davantage à une
sorte de liberté d'indifférence de la
part de la commune et de l'état en ce
qui concerne la distribution ou la non
distribution de cet enseignement
il y a un droit et un devoir qui sont au
dessus de toutes les libertés
c'est le droit et le devoir de
l'instruction qui s'impose au nom d'une
nécessité sociale
fin de citation et c'est au nom de cette
nécessité sociale qui nous semble
essentiel aujourd'hui que l'état puisse
garantir les droits à l'instruction de
tous les enfants parce que l'instruction
nationale est constitutif de notre
république
c'est pour ça que nous voterons ces
amendements merci merlin présidente
merci monsieur brisson
si madame la présidente je ministre je
vous trouve quelque peu crispés cet
après midi jusqu'au point d'ailleurs de
donner un avis défavorable aux
amendements de suppression
je pense que voulait dire favorables
voilà plus d'un an monsieur le ministre
je comprends aux crispations puisque
vous indiquez finalement que
l'instruction en famille ne posaient pas
problème est qu'elle était protégée par
la constitution est un peu plus de deux
ans nous votions ensemble la loi pour
nicolas confiance qu'on me permette de
renforcer le contrôle et nous l'avons
fait très sereinement en vous donnant à
votre demande
les outils nécessaires faudrait sur le
sujet mais sa collègue vous donner
d'abord une conviction intime vous faire
part aussi nos constats et d'une et
études la conviction intime c'est que la
coexistence de propositions éducatives
variés et le signe d'une société apaisée
d'une société plurielle d'une société
moderne respectueuse de la diversité et
c'est donc au nom de la modernité et non
pas du passé que vous avez parlé du
précepte aura que je défendrai
l'instruction en famille un constat
ensuite il a été dit par le rapporteur
au delà des cas d'espèces recensées dans
une sordide politique au doigt mouillé
vous êtes bien incapable depuis des mois
d'été y ait de manière forte
le corollaire qui pourrait exister entre
instruction en famille et menace
séparatiste ni l'ampleur du phénomène ni
celle des dérives ou des infractions
constatées ne sont ici explicités pour
justifier la remise en cause d'un
élément constitutif d'une liberté
fondamentale la liberté d'enseignement
c'est donc sous le coup d'une démocratie
d'émotion parfaite symbole de cet état
inquiets dont je parlais dans lors de la
discussion générale que vous prenez des
mesures disproportionnées par rapport à
l'objectif que vous recherchez une
équipe d'enfer avec le régime
d'autorisation même amendé par
l'assemblée nationale
c'est la liberté de choix des parents
qui est suspecte a priori les parents
doivent se justifier qu'il poursuivre
l'intérêt supérieur de leur propre aux
enfants
face à une puissance publique est
finalement jugés seuls aptes à définir
cet intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
nous passons ainsi de régime de
déclaration avec un contrôle a
posteriori que je ne discute pas un
régime d'autorisation fondée sur le
contrôle sociétal a priori de
l'intention et de la motivation de
lui-même merci madame préville merci
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
tenter quelque chose de difficile
c'est à dire d'être dans la nuance et
pour indiquer que je m'abstiendrai sur
ces amendements
j'ai fait toute une carrière de
professeur dans l'éducation nationale je
suis très attaché à l'école de la
république et c'est pour ça a été pour
moi une période très intéressant de ma
vie mais on n'exerce pas ce métier sans
porter un regard à la fois bienveillant
et lucide
loin de mettre en cause d'ailleurs qui
que ce soit mon mais mon expérience
m'amène à dire que les tous les enfants
ne seront pas s'épanouir à l'école que
ces six que ceci se passe sur de courtes
périodes ou au long cours les parents
qui ont une attention bienveillante à
leurs enfants et qu'ils décèlent soit
une fragilité soit une propension à
apprendre plus vite par imprégnation
soit qu'il soit très curieux de nature
ou apte à entrevoir appréhender puces
par lui-même
cela existe et concerne certes peu
d'enfants mais moi j'estime qu'on
devrait laisser cette liberté comme elle
était précédemment
en tout cas il me semble que ce serait
bien de faire comme si cela n'existait
pas c'est pourquoi je pense qu'il
fallait laisser cette liberté pleine et
entière aux parents et à ce titre là je
ne saurais que trop vous conseiller une
lecture c'est il s'agit du livre de
gerald durrell la trilogie de corfou qui
est une lecture lumineuse qui vous fera
découvrir l'éducation totalement libre
de celui qui deviendra un zoologiste
naturaliste mondialement connus dont le
frère laurent gerra était un écrivain
également connu officier de l'ordre de
l'empiré britannique
je vous laisse découvrir ce magnifique
ouvrage et vous verrez
comment un enfant par lui-même apprend
peut apprendre s'il est déjà curieux
voilà je voulais juste donner ces
témoignages et voilà dire que je ne
voterai pas que je m'abstiens pression
ces amendements merci merci madame mélo
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues choisir que
ses enfants et à l'école publique à
l'école privée choisir pour ses enfants
l'enseignement à distance ou pratiquer
lieu f
tous ces choix témoigne d'une réflexion
d'une application de l'engagement
l'école est obligatoire pour tous les
enfants de france
mais la liberté la liberté d'instruire
son enfant en dehors des bancs de
l'école
selon son choix peut répondre aussi à
des raisons différentes de santé de
handicap
je pense aux enfants autistes qui ne
peuvent intégrer l'école publique faute
de classes adaptées en nombre suffisant
ou parce qu'ils ont des besoins
différents
nombre d'enfants ne sont pas heureux à
l'école et ont besoin de travailler à
leur rythme des enfants perdent
confiance à nous parce que la méthode
d'apprentissage n'est pas adaptée à
leurs besoins
les enfants harcelés à l'école qui ont
la boule au ventre chaque matin peuvent
avoir besoin de l'ietf pour un temps au
moins pour reprendre confiance à noeux
et retrouver goût à la vie l'école à la
maison ce n'est pas faire ce que l'on
veut de ses enfants
c'est faire au mieux pour ses enfants
cela implique de connaître les attendus
du socle commun de justifier ses choix
pédagogiques organisationnel et de
montrer son attachement aux valeurs de
la république
c'est s'investir pour le bien-être et la
réussite de ses enfants
les familles que j'ai pu rencontrer
privilégier la culture et le sport et
leur enfant n'était pas isolé donc
l'argumentation développée par certains
de mes collègues ne tient pas ne nous
trompons pas de débat il ne faut pas
pénaliser les 0,5 pour cent de familles
qui choisissent le f
mais plutôt lutter contre les abus le
séparatisme en renforçant l'encadrement
les mesures de suivi pour ne pas perdre
l'enfant en chemin je crois que nous
sommes tous d'accord choisissons donc de
mieux encadrer d'accompagner
de contrôler pas d'interdire choisissons
la confiance pour tous ceux qui en sont
dignes et respectent des principes de la
république
c'est mon avis personnel et les membres
de mon groupe voteront selon leurs
convictions je vous remercie
merci madame avait suite à la
suppression de l'article la commission a
malgré tout repris un certain nombre de
dispositifs intégrés par le gouvernement
pourquoi nos yeux privilégier le
contrôle a priori notamment par une
application plus systématique est plus
aisé le nombre de familles et en ayant
eu recours au choix de l'école à la
maison a fortement augmenté ce qui rend
les contrôles apostille au a posteriori
et notamment celui administratif réalisé
par le maire très compliqué par ailleurs
le nouveau système proposé au delà de sa
meilleure efficacité vaudra surtout pour
l'avenir
en effet 40% des familles aujourd'hui
concernés sont inscrits dans un parcours
cned classique
il s'agit du plus souvent pour
concernant des enfants souffrant de
handicaps
le nouveau régime d'autorisation ne
modifiera pas cela ensuite un régime
transitoire pour les familles déjà connu
du ministère et qui ne pose aucune
difficulté est prévue dans ce texte il
s'agit donc bien d'un dispositif qui
s'appliquera aux nouvelles familles
souhaitant entrer dans le dispositif est
ainsi il visera à empêcher certains
enfants de fréquenter en fête des écoles
clandestines des structures de
radicalisation 5000 enfants serait
aujourd'hui hors de nos radars et c'est
inacceptable alors que nous avons connu
la semaine dernière certains
durcissement opéré par la majorité
sénatoriale auquel nous sommes avec mon
groupe fermement opposée et nous irons
viendront en conclusion des débats sur
ce contrôle a priori vous iriez donc
vers un assouplissement un deux poids
deux mesures que nous déplorons merci
monsieur seulement
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre lors de l'examen en commission
le sénat a supprimé l'article 21
relatifs à la refonte de l'instruction
en famille cet article 21 prévoyait de
remplacer le régime actuel de
l'instruction en famille soumis à simple
déclaration par une autorisation des
services académiques délivré pour une
durée de un an
c'est un renversement complet de la
liberté d'inscrits d'instruction ceci
pour faire face à une radicalisation
islamique qui utilisent d'instruction
tamil comme outil pour déscolarisés et
isoler les enfants mais à plusieurs
reprises dans des auditions pour évaluer
la pertinence de ce revirement
nous avons demandé des chiffres ou un
ordre de grandeur sur cette
radicalisation dans l'instruction
famille ni le ministre ni les
spécialistes et nous sommes plusieurs à
l'avoir remarqué n'ont été capables
d'évaluer réellement l'ampleur du
phénomène on nous a tout de même pointé
du doigt l'augmentation du nombre
d'enfants en hiver avec le passage de 36
mille enfants 2010 9 à 64000 en 2021
mais ce chiffre est à relativiser
puisque plus de 17000 ans de ses enfants
supplémentaires sont dus à l'abaissement
de l'âge obligatoire de scolarisation de
6 ans à trois ans pour être pour autant
nous restons lucides l'iref peut donner
lieu à un certain nombre de dérives de
pratiques sectaires antirépublicaine et
pas uniquement de la part des salafistes
il nous faut être vigilant et rigoureux
c'est pourquoi nous sommes favorables
aux mesures visant à renforcer les
contrôles de l'instruction à domicile
nous sommes favorables aux mesures
visant à s'assurer que les enfants
suivent un projet pédagogique sérieux
est conforme à nos valeurs nous
préférons l'encadrement plutôt que la
suspicion généralisée nous voterons les
anneaux mandement qui vont dans ce sens
nous souhaitons maintenir la liberté de
faire école à ses enfants chez soi sur
la base d'une simple déclaration tout en
donnant aux autorités compétentes en
matière d'éducation les pouvoirs de
s'assurer d'assurer le contrôle et la
qualité du projet éducatif
mais pour cela il faut leur en donner
les moyens merci merci monsieur
grosperrin
merci président mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le ministre
moi j'ai entendu comme le stéphanois
public dire que c'était un moyen de
lutter contre l'islamisme radical de
supprimer ctfc tf
si on reprend les ferney l'ambition on
peut lui faire dire beaucoup de choses
cher pierre ouzoulias semé lorsqu'il
parle de séparatisme et parle surtout de
foi laïque et il le prendre deux cas
lorsqu'il parle de qualificatifs
professionnel il faut avoir à l'esprit
que dès que jules ferry a été nommé
ministre ou son public il a nommé
ferdinand buisson pendant près de 17 ans
et il a pesé c'est vrai mais
équitablement à nos fondateurs de cette
icône républicaine
mais pour lui la seule origine et l
originalité cette école qui n'est à
personne car elle est à tous elle
appartient également aux familles
consiste à fonder l'éducation publique
non plus sur le séparatisme
professionnelle mais sur la fraternité
nationale ce qu'elle veut c'est lutter
contre l'âme des enfants et des petits
français
donc ce n'est pas la foi qui est mise en
cause mais c'est la haine toutefois
respectable tout n est mauvaise pourquoi
je dis ça parce que si on se réfère
également à ce que disait émile littré
qui a parlé qui appelait les petits
catholique en tout cas les catholiques
selon suffrage universel on peut appeler
également les unes et musulmans selon
suffrage universel pourquoi pourquoi
c'est important parce que ça veut dire
comment donner je ne suis pas sûr que en
voulant supprimer ou on vouloir amender
donc cette instruction à famille on se
dit qu'on s'éloigne pas du résultat
je suis pas sûr qu'on n'arrivera pas à
responsabiliser les familles à une
période où justement chacun à la
pression que les enfants vivent de
manière très individuelle la liberté
maastricht sont la liberté anciennement
sont deux deux notions qu'ils sont très
importantes
lorsque j'entends certains collègues
socialistes nous disent nous dire qu'il
n'ya pas socialisation qu'il n'y a pas
de citoyenneté à l'ecoute des auditions
des personnes que nous avons pu voir et
entendre on s'en rend compte
véritablement qui a un engagement très
fort de la part des parents de la part
des familles ça serait vraiment trop
dommageable de le supprimer
donc si on veut véritablement changé
tout cela et ne pas pu dire entre
guillemets tout un ensemble de personnes
qui font véritablement une qui ont une
mission vis-à-vis de leurs enfants
moi je vous demanderai simplement de
multiplier d'inspection des multiplient
les contrôles de multiplier les règles
enfin que le gouvernement ait beaucoup
d'autorité par rapport à cela un moment
où il faut donner des signaux forts à
tous les français notre république merci
merci même gatel merci madame la
présidente monsieur mini je salue avec
beaucoup de sincérité
votre détermination votre courage et
aussi votre action pour lutter contre
l'embrigadement des enfants au travers
de l'enseignement oui moi je suis
d'accord avec vous l'école est bien le
creuset de la république et le creuset
de la société de limande ses patients
des enfants
mais il existe dans notre pays des
libertés constitutionnelles il me semble
que la liberté de l'enseignement en fait
partie c'est en tout cas le parti pris
que le sénat a retenu lorsque nous avons
discuté des écoles privées hors contrat
je pense monsieur ministe qu'il n'y a
pas effectivement ou à raison de
statistiques de chiffres et que les
chiffres que vous nous indiquez peuvent
apparaître anecdotique insuffisant mais
naturellement et vous avez raison
comme il s'agit de pratiques
clandestines personne n'est capable de
fournir des chiffres
mais un enfant qui est embrigadé est un
enfant de trop et moi je salue votre
envie de préserver l'intérêt de tous les
enfants toutefois peut-on aller contre
une liberté constitutionnelle
de plus monsieur le ministre je crois
qu'ici nous manquons ni courage ni de
lucidité mais je n'ai pas d'exemple de
loi ou des malveillants n'ont pas été
suffisamment habile pour présenter des
dossiers qui au moment d'autorisation ne
pouvait que donner lieu à des
acquiescements je crois que les malins
les malveillants sont trop malicieux
pour s'affranchir d'une loi que nous
pourrions proposer l'enjeu monsieur le
ministre vous le savez vous le faites et
vous le faites avec force et conviction
et constance c'est de contrôler ce qui
se passe pour vraiment surveiller qui
n'est pas l'enfant au radar et je crois
monsieur le ministre
la liberté constitutionnelle elle est
ainsi qu il ya des enfants qui trouvent
matière à épanouissement mais il faut
former les inspecteurs comme vous l'avez
fait il faut systématiser les contrôles
et être exigeant c'est pourquoi je
regrette très sincèrement parce que
j'apprécie plutôt votre engagement et
votre détermination mais je pense que
d'un strict point de vue juridique et
constitutionnel je ne pourrais pas vous
suivre et donc je serais favorable aux
amendements avec toutefois quelques
observations notamment sur la validation
des acquis de l'enseignement famille
ainsi monsieur clés rouge merci madame
la présidente je constate quand même que
l'indignation de la majorité sénatoriale
est à géométrie variable
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire mais
quand même ça nous aura permis
d'entendre notre collègue max brisson
parler de diversité cet après midi sur
une tonalité très différente de celle
qu'il a eue la semaine dernière je le
constate
pour revenir au fond du sujet et pour
parodier pour reprendre les propos de
bénédicte emmerdeur singles la nation
c'est un imaginaire collectif
la nation c'est quelque chose qui se
construit ensemble
construit par des représentations des
représentations qui justement se mettre
en oeuvre dès le départ dès le moment où
tu en es ans on est ensemble
dès le moment on est à l'école il n'est
pas possible de construire la nation sur
des séparatismes et c'est pour ça que je
m'étonne de votre position
quelles que soient les séparatismes ça
peut être effectivement le séparatisme
religieux dont on a parlé ça peut être
aussi du séparatisme social du
séparatisme elithis c'est à dire le fait
de se mettre à part de la nation pour
rester entre soi avec son propre système
de valeurs et ça que ça soit au niveau
religieux au niveau social
c'est un séparatisme qui nous mais
collectivement collectivement en danger
et je ne comprends pas que vous ne
compreniez pas ceci ou que vous fassiez
semblant de ne pas le comprendre et bien
entendu bien entendu
il faut voter ces amendements pour
revenir au texte initial voté par
l'assemblée nationale
merci monsieur paco dont la présidente
ce ministre sur le rapporteur ce
ministre connaissait ou le symbole drôme
de la punition collective
lorsqu'un professeur chahuté par
quelques élèves qui ne parvient pas
identifié décide de sévir contre
l'ensemble de la classe
non seulement il provoque un sentiment
d'injustice chez les innocents qu'il a
ainsi stigmatisé châtié non seulement il
suscite la moquerie de ceux qui n'ont
pas été démasqué non seulement ils
créent une zizanie entre les vrais et
les faux coupable mais il démontre aussi
et surtout son manque d'autorité
son manque de crédibilité certes la
situation plus que préoccupante
dramatique même de petites filles
embrigader enchaîné spirituellement
selon des préceptes totalement contraire
aux valeurs de la république mérite une
réponse ferme aux pays des lumières de
voltaire et de ferry il faut bien
évidemment lutter contre tous les
obscurantismes mais le fils est jeté à
juste titre sur les islamistes radicaux
par cet article 21 ça va aussi à tort
sur les milliers de familles avec cet
article
vous mettez fin brutalement à des choix
de vie un droit une liberté vieille de
150 ans et surtout vous méprisez vous
jeter par dessus bord une denrée social
précieuse est devenu rare la
responsabilité parentale car ces
familles qui ont décidé d'instruire
elles mêmes leurs enfants doivent
assumer et assume un enseignement précis
et préciser les récentes et même
l'actuelle période de confinement ont pu
faire prendre conscience à certains
parents des difficultés de la mission
d'enseigner et nombreux ont été soulagés
de voir leur enfant retrouvé le chemin
de l'école
car il est difficile de professer cet
exigeant chronophage quelle injustice
donc mais aussi quel contresens social
que de démissionner au sens propre
ses parents qui ont fait le choix de la
responsabilité pédagogique
je ne voterai évidemment pas le
rétablissement de l'article matière
merci monsieur assouline oui je ministre
je vais plaider pour le rétablissement
ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est que bien entendu quand cette
liberté a été créée elle n'est pas
supprimée comme vous voulez le répéter
il y avait peut-être besoin de moins de
garde fous pourquoi parce que la
dynamique populaire d'adhésion à l'école
publique
submergée tous les familles voulaient
mettre des enfants dans une école
gratuite et laïque camp alors qu'elles
étaient avant privée et est réservé à
quelques-uns notamment sous la coupe de
l'église et donc c'était ça la dynamique
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une autre
dynamique vous faites semblant d'un coup
d'oublier vous nous avez mis tout sur la
tête
vous avez mis les drapeaux algériens
dans les mairies etc
d'un coup ap quand il s'agit du fonds
l'école celle là c'est là que la
séparation peut être la plus grande
c'est là où on peut mettre dans la tête
de jeunes qui vont devenir des adultes
toutes les valeurs contraires à
l'émancipation à l'autonomie à l'égalité
et à la fraternité à la laïcité
et là d'un coup non il n'ya pas besoin
d'autorisation préalable
non mais c'est incroyable c'est
presqu'une un moment de vérité dans cet
hémicycle sur ce qui motive les uns et
les autres
parce que si c'est la république alors
oui vous ne pouvez pas fermer les yeux
sur le fait qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui de
50 mille élèves sur plus de 10 millions
donc on est en train je vous trouve très
mobilisés pour une question qui est
peut-être en tous les cas comparé au
drapeau algérien dans les mariages
je ne sais pas morales pour conclure
la dynamique aujourd'hui aller inverse
il n'ya pas seulement de la part des
salafistes
on a dit de secte on a dit que l'époque
est à la revendication d'identité à la
place de la communauté de destin et de
la république et donc ce phénomène monte
j'espère que le ministère pourra nous
fournir à un moment donné parce que nos
élus locaux nous disent que ça monte et
donc c'est pour casser cette dynamique
là qui de retirer les merci chers
collègues blick merci pour établir si la
parole est à mme hamm darcos oui merci
madame la présidente je voulais répondre
surtout à mon collègue kerrouche qui
parlait de caricatures ont complètement
tous ces familles quand on choisit
l'instruction en famille d'abord ça
n'est en général pas pour une scolarité
complète et deuxièmement bien évidemment
que on peut on est tous d'accord pour
dire qu'on va essayer de traquer les
enfants et notamment les petites filles
déscolarisées mais honnêtement
al'inverse de ce que dit monsieur
assouline si on en a reçu beaucoup même
si ça représente 50 mille familles
ces cinquante mille familles qui pour la
plupart sont souvent très bien inséré au
sein de la commune et de leur
environnement ce sont des familles qui
en général sont aux associations
culturelles sportives
les enfants ne sont pas cloîtré
simplement pour des raisons de phobie
scolaire de difficultés voire de
précocité ne trouve pas exactement ce
qu'ils voulaient elles vous plaisent
dans l'enseignement public c'est tout et
donc on demande juste cette liberté
pédagogique et on ne peut pas
caricaturer notre note rémi de notre
partie de l'hémicycle en disant que
d'une certaine manière on va être
laxiste par rapport au séparatisme par
rapport à l'islamisme radical c'est
impossible
quelque chose que j'entends la est
complètement débile
monsieur mais non vie oui madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre
l'instruction famille est une liberté
une liberté aujourd'hui déjà encadré
elle est depuis 1882 et donc nous
souhaitons bien évidemment nous
maintenir le régime déclaratif et donc
nous ne nous ne voterons pas
majoritairement donc le rétablissement
de l'article 21
je le disais c'est donc une liberté
importante qui doit être véritablement
garantie et si effectivement des
détournements des contournements aux
réglementations actuelles en vigueur
existait bien je crois qu'il faut mettre
en oeuvre les contrôles nécessaires donc
sans doute renforcer les contrôles sans
doute aussi réaliser davantage de
d'inspection et surtout je crois qu'un
certain nombre de situations relèvent
davantage donc de relève davantage
d'écoles clandestine que d'instruction
famille alors de grâce je pense qu'il
faut véritablement garantir cette
liberté à ses millions millions de
familles milliers de familles je veux
dire qu'ils y ont recours
si monsieur marc madame la présidente
monsieur le monsieur le ministre je
voudrais revenir un petit peu sur
l'amendement 527 je ne sais pas vraiment
s'il faut un inspecteur d'académie
dédiés à nestlé
l'instruction en famille comment ça se
passe aujourd'hui le dyson l'inspecteur
d'académie délègue aux é u n 12 et
specter de l'éducation nationale qui eux
mêmes des legs de conseillers
pédagogiques
le fait d'aller contrôler sur place si
l'instruction en famille et bien fait ou
pas on ne peut pas dire que les
conseillers pédagogiques qui ont de
longues années de pratique scolaire
derrière eux soit complètement
discrédité pour ce faire non ce qui est
important c'est le fait que sony ait
souvent et ça c'est pas de cas
aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que des contrôles soient
beaucoup plus nombreux et ce pourquoi je
plaide c'est cela parce qu'on s'est
aperçu par exemple pendant le
confinement de quelques mois que des
enfants même dans des classes décroché
on peut
c'est aussi que des enfants qui se tue
qui sont en instruction en famille qui
pendant un an n'ont pas été contrôlés
décroche plus donc je que je souhaite
vraiment ce n'est pas tellement que l'on
est un inspecteur d'académie dédié à
cela mais que l'on ait beaucoup plus de
contrôle pour destruction en famille
monsieur fialaire madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
moi je voterais pour les amendements de
rétablissement de l'article 21 par
respect des principes de la république
certes il ya la liberté et les enfants
viennent à l'école d'ailleurs pour
l'acquérir cette liberté il y à
l'égalité des chances que leur apportent
l'école et puis il ya la fraternité et
je ne pense pas que l'école soit quelque
chose de nuisibles pour apprendre la
fraternité la fraternité c'est pas
préférer son frère à son cousin son
cousin son voisin et son voisin
étrangers c'est même pas préférer son
frère à ses camarades de classe la
fraternité c'est considérer chacun comme
son frère
et c'est apprendre à découvrir par
l'enseignement qu'on reçoit l'école et
aussi parce qu'on vit à l'école on a
tous dans notre entourage
les gens qui nous ont apporté beaucoup
parce qu'on les a côtoyés sur les bancs
de l'école et pas simplement par ce que
nos parents ou ce que nos enseignants
nous ont appris et pour toutes ces
raisons je défends donc ces amendements
je voudrais dire aussi que j'ai beaucoup
entendu la semaine dernière par en
parler de naïveté dans cet hémicycle
je crois que il n'ya pas que la naïveté
vis-à-vis du port de voile
ou de signes religieux faut pas non plus
avoir de naïveté en rire l'instruction
la famille dans quelques familles et
auprès de quelques-uns
et puis un autre notre référence que
j'ai beaucoup entendu aussi la semaine
dernière c'est référence à robert
badinter
pour ma part je crois que l'autorisation
plutôt que la déclaration comme nous
sera proposée est un bien petit
sacrifice pour défendre des valeurs
comme celles de la république
si la parole est à monsieur le questeur
sueur merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
une seule question pourquoi food rions
nous priver d enfants qu bien fait
d'aller à l'école d' aller à l'école
c'est être d'abord ensemble les uns à
côté des autres
quelles que soient les opinions
politiques religieuses philosophiques
des parents quelle que soit leur origine
c'est être les uns à côté des autres et
non pas isolé des autres c'est apprendre
ensemble et c'est pourquoi dans
l'histoire de france
l'école et la république ont cheminé de
concerts qu'ils se sont appuyés l'une et
l'autre qu'ils marchent ensemble
alors bien sûr il y à des cas où ce
n'est pas possible et c'est pourquoi le
texte du gouvernement repris par notre
amendement
il prévoit des cas pour lesquels il y a
une autorisation mais enfin pourquoi
priver nos enfants de ce bonheur de
l'école alors c'est tout
mais oui même s'il y a des problèmes
si vous croyez qu'il n'y a pas des
problèmes lorsque l'enfant est tout seul
dans certaines familles et dans
certaines conditions et pour les raisons
qui ont été dit tout à l'heure par
monsieur le ministre
donc l'école c'est positif et nous
sommes tellement nombreux ici surtout
c'est bon en avoir bénéficié à lui de
voir tellement c'est tout alors vous
savez ces mêmes paroles résonnent
toujours ici voilà donc voilà donc
l'idéal de la question l'instruction
publique est obligatoire un enseignement
public
partant de l'école de village et montant
2 degrés en degré jusqu'au collège de
france
les portes de la science toute grande
ouverte à toutes les intelligences
partout il ya un champ partout il ya un
esprit qu'il y est un livre pas de
communes sor école victor hugo mais si
même un président le million merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
l'instruction en famille c'est forcément
la garantie de la liberté d'enseignement
l'instruction en famille c'est une
chance pour une grande majorité
d'enfants la possibilité d'apprendre
avec des méthodes pédagogiques
alternatifs les reproches faits à l'iref
ne sont étayées par aucun chiffre aucune
statistique alors loin de moi l'idée
d'idéaliser l'instruction en famille
mais la solution c'est forcément
enfin des moyens pour contrôler cette
instruction en famille si l'état est
défaillant dans les contrôles
ce n'est pas offert me d'en payer le
prix préservons cette liberté
d'enseignement et soyons lucides chers
collègues
l'école n'est pas une garantie de mixité
la mixité elle peut prendre d'autres
formes de multiples formes donc bien
entendu le groupe union centriste ne
reverra pas les les amendements de
rétablissement de cet article et suivra
le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président retailleau
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
dans vos propos il ya quelques instants
vous avez beaucoup de bienveillance
vis-à-vis de l'instruction en famille
c'est oublier d'où vient cet article 21
il vient comme l'a très bien dit le
rapporteur de la volonté du président
république qui avait indiqué qu'il
fallait supprimer l'instruction
obligatoire
il vient d'une première rédaction qui
avait été d'ailleurs étrillé par le
conseil d'état qui était toujours sur
cette ligne là cet article est mal non
il est né de cette volonté de supprimer
l'instruction aux familles alors
aujourd'hui on peut toujours aller
chercher des arguments un peu
collatéraux mais la volonté initiale
elle était celle là et je crois qu'on a
avec l'article 21 du cher collègue une
idée de la malfaçon de ce texte de ce
que nous lui reprochons au fond car en
réalité parce qu'il est mal ciblé ce que
le conseil d'état lui même a reconnu il
est trop accommodant lorsqu'il faut être
ferme et nous avons fait des
propositions nous avons déposé des
amendements que nous avons voté pour
plus de fermeté que ce soit sur les
signes ostentatoires sur le délit
notamment de séparatisme et sur bien
d'autres choses parce qu'ils étaient
trop pas comme andorre trop faible sur
ces sujets là et il est liberticide
quand il s'agit de porter atteinte aux
libertés
sans encore une fois que cette
justification n'ait été donnée ni
d'ailleurs dans l'exposé des motifs en
tout cas dans l'étude d'impact ni dans
les différentes auditions ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que il institue un
régime d'exception or mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre un régime
d'exception est tout sauf un régime de
liberté
nous sommes attachés à cette liberté
qu'on considère comme fondamental la
liberté de l'instruction l'instruction
obligatoire d'ailleurs ne vaut pas dire
la scolarisation obligatoire
ça a été révélé tout à l'heure
évidemment depuis l'article 4 de la loi
de mars
82 aucune république aucun gouvernement
n'a atteint cette liberté qui est
extrêmement importante
même à la tribune je les cite l autre
jour clemenceau qui avait indiqué
lorsqu'il s'agissait de la doctrine de
l'absorption totale du monopole de
l'état avait indiqué qu'il était contre
il était pour la liberté
et malheureusement je pense que
récemment dans notre histoire de nos
républiques et la vème république jamais
un gouvernement n'aura porté autant
atteinte aux libertés la liberté
d'instruction la liberté d'expression
avec la loi via la liberté d'information
avec les doigts si jamais tu as les
balles
eh bien je pensais c'est bien de
combattre libéralisme à l'extérieur
nancy est votée en france merci
même si le gouv merci à la présidente
monsieur le ministre j'ai l'impression
qu'à l'origine de cet article 21 il ya
quand même un constat qui est inquiétant
sur l'augmentation très importante du
nombre d'enfants qui reçoivent cette
fameuse f
alors moi je suis lui la nièvre quand je
regarde la carte de mon département il y
à des zones géographiques très vaste
dans lesquelles il n'y a plus d'école de
la république physique c'est à dire que
bien évidemment on propose une solution
de scolarisation aux enfants mais ça
veut dire qu'il ya des gamins de trois
ans qu'ils doivent prendre un bus
scolaire le matin fort des trajets
parfois très longs négocié avec le
conseil régional pour l'organisation des
transports scolaires avec des arrêts de
bus qui sont parfois très loin tout cela
en plus être pénalisant pour
l'attractivité de nos territoires
m'amène à faire ce constat
monsieur le ministre c'est que si vous
voulez pallier éventuellement à
l'augmentation de l'instruction en
famille alors laissé ouvertes les
classes et les écoles dans nos villages
m
même la présidente rossignol merci à la
présidente
le rôle du législateur s'est souvent de
faire l' équilibre de trouver le point
de rencontre entre les libertés et les
droits
en l'espèce il ya une liberté que la
liberté éducative c'est le départ en épi
lui a des droits
ceux qui sont reconnus aux enfants par
la convention internationale des droits
de l'enfant
si je lis ce que le résumé que l'unicef
organisation que personne ne peut
soupçonner de mener des batailles
idéologiques contre les intérêts des
familles l'unicef dit que l'enfant a le
droit d'aller à l'école et le droit
d'avoir des loisirs
c'est un droit de l'enfant le droit à
une socialisation le droit aussi à
rencontrer d'autres idées que les
siennes d'autres idées celle de sa
famille le droit se former une opinion
pour devenir un citoyen le droit
développer son esprit critique
tout cela ce sont les droits de l'enfant
est ce que nous visons à faire avec les
amendements d'établissement de l'article
c'est à garantir une convention que nous
avons signée la convention des droits de
l'enfant qui garantit le droit d'aller à
l'école je rajouter un autre paramètre
qui à ma connaissance un pas été encore
évoqué cet après midi l'école est le
lieu on détecte et on décède les
maltraitances faites aux enfants un
enfant qui ne va pas à l'école un enfant
qui vit enfermé devant la cedh dans la
sphère familiale
juste pour respecter les ailes dimension
idéologique et dogmatique de ses parents
ces enfants là il n'a personne pour
constater et pour diagnostiquer qu'il
est victime de violences or dans les
familles perverse au même titre que les
hommes violents éloigne les femmes
victimes de tout ceci bilité de leur
famille les pères violent les familles
perverse déscolarisent leurs enfants
pour pouvoir exercer sur eux
ne me faites pas dire ce que je n'ai pas
dit je n'ai pas dit que toutes les
familles qui pratiquent l'instruction en
famille sont des familles perverse et
dit que les familles perverse
déscolarisent leurs enfants ce n'est pas
la même chose pour les comprendre la
différence le croit donc pour cette
raison la raclée
ne pouvons pas priver un enfant du droit
qu'il a aussi aussi à être soumis au
contrôle qu'exerce une collectivité
humaine la collectivité éducative pour
le protéger des maltraitances qu'ils
subirent à la maison et puis nous avons
prévu les dérogations pour les enfants
malheureux à l'école il y en a
malheureusement pour ceux dont les
parents veulent aller faire le tour du
monde en bateau et pour en apprendre à
leurs enfants et à lire et à découvrir
le monde
pour ceux qui sont malades tout ça est
prévue l'article 21 ses larmes elle
garantit les droits de l'enfant merci
monsieur vial vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je partage les
intentions qui vous ont conduit à mettre
en place ce régime d'autorisation comme
beaucoup je pense de mes collègues nous
reconnaissons aussi qu'il puisse exister
des dérives sur ce modèle de ce modèle
d'éducation
elles peuvent d'ailleurs être
séparatistes ou d'une autre tout autre
nature
mais nous reconnaissons tous aussi que
l'instruction famille est à la fois une
liberté et peut être aussi une solution
parfois une meilleure solution que
l'école dans certaines situations qui
peuvent le justifier
nous sommes nombreux ici je pense avoir
été avoir été maire ou adjoint en charge
des affaires scolaires avoir dû être
confrontés à cette instruction aux
familles confrontées à des situations
très particulières on vous la corde des
situations que l'école de la république
parfois moins bien que la famille ne
pouvait régler car la situation
spécifique de l'enfant pouvait le
pouvais le justifier
et nous vivons dans une société de
liberté cette liberté s'exerce dans un
cadre un cadre qui doit respecter les
principes de la république ce que nous
fixons devons contribuer à fixer
aujourd'hui
mais cette liberté donc s'inscrit dans
ce cadre
et notre rôle c'est de fixer ce cadre et
de veiller à son respect dit veiller
comment d'y veiller par un contrôle un
contrôle qui s'exerce déjà aujourd'hui
qui s'exercent souvent tardivement
on a tous encore été une fois confronté
dans nos exercices d'élus locaux
oh des contrôles qui arrive en fin
d'année scolaire et une année une année
s'est passé le besoin peut-être le plus
pressant que l'on a aujourd'hui c'est de
renforcer ses moyens de contrôle je
pense que c'est tout l'enjeu qu'on a
besoin de contrôler plus rapide qu'on a
besoin de réactivité face à un
signalement qu'on n'a pas qu'on
rencontre pas toujours sur le terrain et
que les personnes qui contrôlent ont
besoin de moyens pour réagir après ce
contrôle est donc je pense que c'est le
l'equilibre qui est proposé par le
rapporteur de revenir à cette situation
de liberté qui ne dépend que d'une
déclaration mais de renforcer ses moyens
de contrôle pour ne pas nier les
intentions qui sont les vôtres et qui
s'appuie sur des faits des faits est
effectivement réel et et je rejoins les
arguments de mon collègue pâques au tout
à l'heure sur la punition collective qui
de mémoire a été interdite par votre
prédécesseur monsieur fillon quand il
était ministre de l'éducation nationale
il y a une forme d'injustice a englobé
pour régler un problème angle à
généraliser ce problème mais si c'est
juste salué aujourd'hui l'instruction
famille est devenue la règle pour
quelques jours sans déclarations ni
autorisation vol est à madame tetuanui
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
laporte monsieur le ministre
bien sûr que je souscris totalement à
tout ce qui a été dit surtout long
lorsqu'on parle de l'éducation de nos
enfants
oui au respect des lois de la république
oui au respect des trois devise de la
république liberté égalité fraternité
mais il y à des exceptions monsieur le
ministre et je veux partager un peu ici
avec vous chers collègues les
spécificités les exceptions de nos
territoires ultramarins il y a deux
phénomènes
chez nous on pollue midi surtout il y à
toutes ces familles qui arrivent en
bateau savez bien que on a beaucoup de
marins qui naviguent et qui arrive dans
le zoo avec des enfants à bord qui sont
partis de chez eux après plus d'un an de
navigation est bien sûr que les parents
s'occupent heures
instruire de ces enfants là parce que
nous avons rencontré certains
comment voulez vous monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui et elle dira où les obligés
dans l'hôtel dans notre territoire à
faire une obligation
alors que la simple déclaration non mais
je parle pas je le concret de ce qui se
passe chez nous deuxième phénomène en
polynésie française
118 il ya pas des lycées partout quand
un gamin doit faire aller au collège en
sixième il faut qu'ils quittent son
auteur plus de trois mois ou six mois
d'où certains résultats des courses
france c'est par des parents les
problème sociétal qui vient s'agglutiner
avec les parents ont décidé tout
simplement tout simplement de les
instruire aux familles pas choix par
choix et c'est plus pratique chez nous
mais bien sûr que je soutiens
l'instruction aux familles si simple
déclaration merci mais si madame carmen
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
finalement nous n'aurons jamais autant
parlé de liberté que depuis à la reprise
de cette séance
et comme on est en deuxième semaine on
peut se dire très simplement les choses
si certains veulent nous emmener dans un
jeu qu'ils y ont essayé la semaine
dernière il n'y aurait pas ici les
défenseurs de la liberté les ennemis de
la liberté est derrière parce qu'à
travers finalement les différentes
interventions sur cette question de
l'instruction en famille se laisse
entendre qu'il y à la liberté celle de
l'instruction
mais de quelle liberté parlons et de la
liberté pour qui parce que il y as
certainement plein de parents qui se
disent que leur enfant n'est pas heureux
à l'école que leur enfant est parfois
victime de harcèlement qui se disent que
peut-être que les méthodes que l'on
propose
sont pas les bonnes pour le
développement de leurs propres enfants
et il y as pour autant ces milliers de
parents qui n'ont pas d'autres solutions
parce qu'ils doivent aller travailler
parce que ils n'ont pas la possibilité
de s'arrêter de prendre une année de
prendre six mois de prendre trois mois
de prendre deux ans pour pouvoir faire
l'école à leurs enfants parce que
finalement oui il y a une chose autour
ne parle pas beaucoup depuis la semaine
dernière c'est qu'il ya un séparatisme
qui est réel dans notre pays entre celui
de ceux qui ont les moyens et de ceux
qui ne l'ont pas de ceux qui subissent
et de ceux qui décident mais vous voyez
sur cette question de l'instruction je
pense que c'était le camp parce que oui
oui certains aujourd'hui utilisent cela
à des fins tout autre pour effectivement
empêché l'éducation des jeunes filles
des petits garçons et les formater oui
il y as certainement de très beaux
exemples on en a tous de ces familles
idéal qui alors qu'elles se sont privés
de toit zir pendant deux ans pendant un
an tout arrêter pour faire un tour du
monde à vélo en caravanes camping cars
avait en bateau en ce que vous voulez
pour faire découvrir à leurs enfants
la beauté de ce monde et continuer de
leur apprendre à lire et à écrire
mais il ya aussi la réalité de ces
milliers de femmes et d'hommes qui sont
un pays et qui au quotidien et bien eux
ne peuvent pas faire ses choix
la liberté elle n'est pas que pour
quelques-uns doit être pour tous et oui
l'école publique présente sur tous nos
territoires assure mais seulement cette
liberté même se construire comme citoyen
saint germain en laye à tous les enfants
de la république si l'ademe boyer merci
madame la présidente
mes chers collègues effectivement on
parle beaucoup de liberté et c'est
normal de parler de liberté quand on
sait que cette liberté elle est
consacrée notamment dans la déclaration
des droits de l'homme dans ses articles
2 et 4 pour celle d'enseigner et aux
parents de choisir
pourquoi aujourd'hui vouloir punir tout
le monde parce qu'on ne peut simplement
réprimer certains usages qu'ils ne sont
pas bons
pourquoi vouloir frapper tout le monde
alors que ils vous avaient les moyens
aujourd'hui de contrôler plus de
contrôler mieux ce qui dérive j'ai été
très surprise lors de l'examen de ce
texte de voir combien de familles
combien d'associations
combien de personnes ont fait appel à
nous et je pense surtout les bandes
cette assemblée pour défendre cette
liberté d'instruction pour défendre ce
choix des familles parce que il ne
s'agit pas du choix de quelques-uns qui
ont les moyens
il s'agit souvent aussi de choix qui
s'impose aux parents soit parce que
l'enfant a des difficultés
soit parce qu'il est dans une zone
isolée soit parce qu'il y a des
spécificités qu'on a sont nos
territoires d'outre-mer ou sous des sous
des territoires éloignés et cette
liberté là elle doit être préservé elle
doit être préservée d'autant plus que
jamais vous ne parviendrez à régler les
difficultés que nous rencontrons avec le
totalitarisme islamique en supprimant
l'instruction en famille on sait très
bien que c'est à travers plein de choses
d'ailleurs que nous avons voté au sénat
et que nous apprêtons encore à voter sur
les articles qui viennent que nous
parviendrons à lutter contre 7 contre
cette volonté qui est en train de
vouloir s'imposer à contre nos principes
alors bien sûr qu'il faut préserver
cette liberté bien sûr qu'il faut
permettre à la france de garder cette
spécificité de l'école publique de
l'école sous contrat et de l'instruction
en famille il ne s'agit pas encore de
priver les français de liberté je crois
qu'ils l'ont as ils ont été assez avec
les mesures qui sont proposés depuis
quelques années donc aujourd'hui
préservons ce droit préservant cette
liberté pour les familles merci la
parole est au président la faune si
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
finalement ce cet article fait débat et
ce n'est pas surprenant pas plus
surprenant qu'il n'a fait débat du reste
à l'assemblée nationale où je crois
qu'il a été débattu pendant plus de cinq
heures ce texte n'est pas un texte sur
l'école ni sur l'instruction
c'est un texte sur le séparatisme et
vous avez
et préciser dans votre propos liminaire
que l'objectif à travers le nouveau
dispositif que vous proposez était de
lutter contre la dérive séparatiste
c'est bien dans cette optique que nous
l'avons examiné avec beaucoup
d'attention en commission de la culture
et de et de l'éducation
où en sommes-nous dans l'âme
l'élaboration de ce nouveau cadre
le gouvernement proposait un cadre très
restrictif d'autorisation avec un
certain nombre de critères trois
critères trois critères qui ont été
jugés insuffisants par nos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale qui ce qu'ils en
ont ajouté un quatrième un critère qui
fait référence à la situation propre de
l'enfant et à l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant
on le sait bien l'intention était
louable c'est à dire de permettre à des
familles
on a cité à plusieurs reprises mais le
cas des familles qui partent faire le
tour du monde mais il ya d'autres
objectifs dans les familles peut-être
pour des questions pédagogiques parfois
d'instruire l'objectif était louable
c'était 2 à travers ce quatrième critère
de donner un peu de souplesse à un
dispositif qu'ils étaient il faut bien
le reconnaître très restrictive tel que
proposé par le gouvernement
souplesse mais aussi et je rejoins les
propos tenus tout à l'heure qu'une
famille qui voudra s'engouffrer dans
cette souplesse à des fins malveillantes
et afin de contourner le système
dans la rédaction de l'assemblée
nationale pourra très bien le faire et
c'est pour ça que nous avons cherché
tout en ayant à l'esprit
et l'élue du val-de-marne que je suis
n'est pas naïf sur les dérives que vous
pouvez constater actuellement c'est pour
ça que nous avons cherché un système qui
a à la fois garantit la liberté parce
que c'est un élément important et
fondamental parce qu'on ne touche pas de
manière anecdotique et un dispositif qui
a quasiment 140 ans nous avons cherché à
la fois préserver cette liberté tout en
renforçant à la fois les moyens
d'identification
parce que c'est une des clés de la lutte
contre les familles qui dévoie le
système et de contrôle pour qu'ils
soient plus rapides et plus efficaces
est-ce que entre le système éducation
assemblée nationale et notre système
l'un est plus efficace que l'autre
sur le plan de l'objectif principal
celui de lutter contre les familles qui
utilisent le système
j'ai tendance à penser que le nôtre est
plus efficace et finalement c'est ça qui
compte puisque en plus nous maintenons
le principe de liberté
merci alors je vais mettre au revoir
l'amendement 120 pardon monsieur rythm
and we will miss et mini ce oui monsieur
rythm and d'abord et ensuite vous
donnera la parole aux six ministres
merci madame résidents pour reprendre
les paroles de ma collègue laure darcos
je me demandais si je devenais pas un
peu débile et je me posais la question
mais à quel moment dans l'argumentation
mon amendement
j'ai parlé d'interdire ou de supprimer
l'instruction en famille gergy ressasser
et puis je me suis dit mais jamais bien
au contraire j'ai commencé mon argument
par dire l'instruction en famille à
toute sa justification
elle doit pouvoir se faire et même dans
certains cas elle est même nécessaire
g je me demandais si j'étais pas devenus
des bills en me rappelant les débats de
la semaine dernière et en me mettant
bien dans les débats de cette semaine et
je me dis mais non mais t'es pas
complètement gaga parce que les mêmes
qui la semaine dernière nous disait
l'école de la république doit être au
coeur des débats
c'est au coeur de l'école de la
république je cite c'est au coeur des
débats de l'école de la république qu'on
trouvera les réponses les mêmes
cherchent à m'expliquer aujourd'hui moi
qui suis un enfant de l'école de la
république
et j'aime pas parler de ma vie privée
mais dont l'école de la république m'a
sauvée par rapport à une situation
familiale spéciale je veux dit mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut basculer d'une
semaine à l'autre
dans ses arguments face à un débat aussi
important que l'école la république moi
j'aimerais avant de voter que si vous me
permettez chacun se pose la question
oseriez vous dire
que l'école de la république vous a
apporté des éléments aussi mineur est
remplaçable dans votre développement
votre construction qu'aujourd'hui vous
auriez pu vous en passez vous vos
enfants
ma conviction est que il n'est pas
question de supprimer l'enseignement en
famille mais qu'on doit remettre au
coeur des débats est au coeur de
l'instruction l'école de la république
marianne ne s'incline pas devant la
volonté d'un petit nombre
merci avant de vous passer la parole
monsieur le ministre je vais demander à
chacun d'entre vous là où il ya beaucoup
de petites discussions de droite et de
gauche
non mais qui peuvent gêner les orateurs
alors je vous demander de le faire juste
un petit peu en dessous
pas du tout monsieur assouline monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je ne vais pas
être long puisque si j'avais fait un
discours liminaire j'ai reparlé
aujourd'hui mais je ne peux pas ne pas
répondre à tout ce que j'ai entendu
d'abord en rappelant ce que j'ai dit
dans mon discours liminaire c'est-à-dire
il ya quatre façons d'instruire les
enfants france il ya l'école publique
l'école privée sous contrat et que le
privé hors contrat et l'instruction en
famille et donc nous n'avons jamais dit
que nous supprimions l'instruction en
famille et dans de multiples
interventions
j'ai entendu certains intervenir comme
si nous voulions supprimés l'instruction
en famille et donc ce sénateur paco vous
avez parlé de punition collective moi je
vous parlais de copie hors sujet c'est à
dire que il y a plein de beaucoup de
moments où on est hors sujet et ça me
donne le sentiment que l'on fait exprès
de faire peur pour nous empêcher de
faire une oeuvre salubre c'est à dire
nous attaquer un problème qui existe
pour de vrai qui est un angle mort de la
république alors j'entends aussi
monsieur le sénateur brisson m'inviter
en fait à être débonnaire vis-à-vis de
la république c'est un luxe qu'on peut
pas se permettre quand on est dans ma
fonction
monsieur le sénateur je ne suis pas du
tout crispé je suis juste
cohérent avec ce que je vous dis et
c'est à cette cohérence comme l'a fait
mme sur les sénateurs yetman que
j'invite tout le monde
j'entends parfois des gens dire la
laïcité mais et monsieur le sénateur
brisson même amassé attriste mais comme
les sénateurs
mesdames et sa triste et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous sens parfois venir
avec moi quand je lutte contre ce la
laïcité mais aujourd'hui j'entends des
gens dire la république mais où l'école
de la république mais et monsieur le
sénateur rythm and as tout à fait raison
de dire que quand on parle de
l'instruction famille on parle en creux
de l'école de la république
bien entendu et c'était évident dans
certaines interventions qu'on a entendu
et donc oui ce texte parle de l'école de
la république parce que c'est important
qu'elles rendent continue à rassembler
le maximum d'enfants dans notre pays
même s'il ya évidemment différentes
formes de faire nous n'avons jamais
prétendu jamais que l'instruction en
famille devait se terminer
je ne vais pas je ne vais pas revenir
sur la question de de la liberté sur le
président retailleau vous êtes toujours
très sévère sur c'est sur ces questions
là même si on pourrait faire des
comparaisons différents gouvernements et
des libertés que les uns ou les autres
ont plus ou moins respectée dans
différents champs mais attention à la
liberté au pluriel contre liberté au
singulier
il ya parfois une contradiction et ça a
été dit éloquemment par certains entre
l'état de droit est ce qu'on peut
appeler la société de droit l'état de
droit ça suppose une cohérence du droit
ça suppose que l'on maintienne par une
colonne vertébrale la république parce
qu'il y a dû comme un état de droit ce
n'est pas une multiplicité de droit que
chacun peut brandir quand ça l'arrangé
quand ça n'arrange pas etc ou à la fin
ce serait finalement la liberté du plus
fort parce que on affirme sa force que
soit sa force économique ou sa force
juridique parce qu'on sait mobiliser de
manière habile là si on veut maintenir
la république bien droite on a besoin de
ne pas avoir sur combat des droits
permanent et cette capacité soit à se
dire victime soit et
là j'entends beaucoup de gens se dire
victimes alors qu'ils ne le sont pas ou
à brandir c'est droits individuels face
au commun on a besoin de commun est
évidemment l'école c'est le commun que
ce soit l'école de république ou
d'ailleurs d'autres formes scolaire mais
l'école c'est le commun et ce commun on
en a besoin et donc si dans chaque débat
chacun propose prend position pour
défendre les droits de tel ou tel
secteur contre le droit avec un grand d
ou contre l'état de droit alors
progressivement c'est la république qui
s'affaiblit et donc c'est pas une
position facile que la mienne on le voit
bien des certains qui parfois ont pu
m'attaquer sur certains sujets me
soutiennent certains qui ont pu me
soutenir en attaque c'est bien que y
compris la sénatrice gatel qui a donné
son nom à une loi importante et que j'ai
soutenu fortement en son temps parce que
j'obéissais à cette logique
eh bien je pense que aujourd'hui on doit
être tous indépendamment des partis
politiques auxquels on appartient
face à sa responsabilité et celle là
n'est pas mince parce qu'encore une fois
il s'agit pas de supprimer l'instruction
en famille tout ce qu'ils vont faire
semblant
en votant contre notre article 21 ou
contre le rétablissement de l'article 21
aujourd'hui tout ce qu'ils vont faire
semblant d'être dans une sorte de
défense de toutes les formes
d'instruction en famille et de défense
donc des familles qui font bien
l'instruction en famille en réalité sont
dans la copie hors sujet dans le
meilleur des cas ou dans la démagogie
dans le pire des cas parce que ça n'est
pas vrai que c'est ce que nous visons
or c'est l'occasion de leur et de le
répéter aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ce que
nous faisons donc arrêtons de faire
semblant de croire que nous visons à
côté de la cible
je n'ai cessé de dire que ça n'était pas
le cas et ça a été rappelé par plusieurs
ici donc arrêtons de faire ainsi en
revanche que dites-vous par rapport au
phénomène que nous visons bel et bien
j'entends très bien ce que ce qu'a dit
monsieur le président l'instant sur la
nécessité de
2 vous d'avoir une vision la plus
protectrice des libertés des familles
dans le dispositif que nous retiendrons
finalement eh bien j affirme de nouveau
que le régime d'autorisation étaient
évidemment un régime de protection
c'est un régime de protection des
libertés bien sûr c'est un régime je le
répète de protection des droits de
l'enfant un enfant dont on constate à
posteriori et merci madame la sénatrice
rossignol de ce que vous avez dit dont
on constate à posteriori que ses droits
ont été violés c'est des mois qu'on a
dans lesquels on a accepté que ses
droits sont violés
un enfant donc pour lequel on a prévenu
le fait qu'il pouvait avoir des droits
violés et évidemment un enfant que l'on
aura davantage sauver et quand bien même
il y en aurait peut se peut la m'importe
beaucoup et malheureusement il n'en a
pas tout alors j'entends aussi toutes
les objections sur le thème du
dénombrement mais c'est vrai qu'un
problème de dénombrement c'est tout à
fait juste de le dire pas complet
d'ailleurs nous savons qu'il ya soixante
mille 68 69 65 mille enfants maastricht
en famille nous savons aussi que ce
chiffre a explosé depuis dix ans nous
savons qu'il explose tout
particulièrement comme par hasard dans
les territoires comme le vôtre madame la
sénatrice darcos où il ya justement du
du séparatisme et donc le bel au
séparatisme du plateau sac ce n'est
peut-être pas le même que le séparatisme
d'evry c'est possible mais séparatisme
il ya et
il se trouve qu on le constate sous
d'autres angles et comme par hasard
c'est l'endroit où l'instruction en
famille se développe aussi qu'au maximum
alors on fait semblant de pas voir cela
pour satisfaire d'autres groupes qui
font semblant d'être atteint par cette
fois alors qu'ils ne le seront pas et on
fait une sorte de calcul politique
autour de ça est ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est digne du sujet de la
république 1 vous êtes moins débonnaires
d'un seul coup monsieur le sénateur
parce qu'on arrive à quelque chose qui
pointe une contradiction c'est la
laïcité sans mais la république sens
mais c'est la république intégral la
liberté intégral l'école intégral nous
en avons besoin dans le respect des
libertés ce qui fait que nous n'allons
pas mettre fin à l'instruction en
famille non nous ne mettrons pas faire
l'instruction en famille en revanche
nous protégerons les droits de l'enfant
autant que nous le pourrons et ça ira
avec notre protection de la république
monsieur magny vous avez demandé la
parole la vision sioniste ce sujet aura
été largement débattue mais nous y
étions dion puisque c'est un morceau
important de ce projet de loi il est
bien évident que sur nos bancs du groupe
socialiste et de la gauche j'imagine
nous n'avons nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de gérer les affaires de
l'éducation nationale dans ce pays nous
n'avons jamais proposé de revenir sur ce
qui permettait lancé l'éducation en
famille
mais la loi de 2013 par exemple de
refondation de l'école ne le prévoyait
pas et laisser les choses en l'état
toutefois aujourd'hui on peut penser que
nécessite la situation a évolué ça a été
rappelé par même d'entre nous et je
dirais que à l'issue de ce débat
si on votait on ne votait pas ce retour
à l'article 21 c'est l'école qui
perdrait ça signifie qu' on aurait donné
la victoire à ce qui aujourd'hui est
minoritaire considère qui est considéré
nécessaire pour un certain nombre de
familles certes mais prévu par
dérogation et je crois que l'école
mérite aujourd'hui qu'on revienne à ce
système
on arrive à ce système d'autorisation
qui n'existe pas et on dira la même
chose pour les établissements scolaires
hors contrat toujours merci monsieur le
président monsieur le questeur bas parmi
ses ministres je ne partage pas votre
point de vue mais m'exprimer avec autant
de conviction que vous venez de le faire
je pense que votre texte porte une
atteinte grave à la liberté de
l'enseignement je pense que je pense que
la liberté d'enseigner en famille est
gravement atteinte par ce texte
je pense d'ailleurs par analogie avec la
liberté d'association que lorsqu'il y à
50 ans la loi anti casseurs a été annulé
par le conseil constitutionnel c'était
sa première grande décision protectrice
des libertés
c'était au nom de la liberté de
l'association parce qu'on passait d'un
régime déclaratif ce qui est le cas pour
l'enseignement en famille
un régime qui s'apparentait qui
s'apparentait seulement un régime
d'autorisation eh bien voyez vous il ne
s'agit pas aujourd'hui de créer comme
vous avez laissé entendre
l'enseignement en famille il existe déjà
et donc dans la cohérence de notre
approche sur la liberté de
l'enseignement nous admettons ce
principe mais il s'agit bien avec votre
texte de le remettre en cause je vois
bien qu'il ya des enjeux collatéraux
qu'il faut absolument traité je ne
voudrais pas que des enfants de la
république aille à l'école coranique au
lieu de recevoir un enseignement mais
c'est à vous de proposer les moyens pour
éviter cet excès sans pour autant
remettre en cause une liberté
fondamentale
mais alors pour l'amendement 120 j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par la commission
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable la visite
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement et le scrutin est ouvert
non
monsieur le ministre vous êtes favorable
sur le 120 vous avez vous aviez dit
favorable sur votre amendement mais pas
sur le 120 donc sur le 120 vous est
défavorable
oui c'est ça donc vous êtes favorable
aux 120 donc je leur signale donc l'avis
de la commission est donc défavorable et
l'avis du gouvernement est favorable
merci alors voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 101 sur l'amendement 120 compte
tenu de l'ensemble des délégations de
vote accordés par les sénateurs au
groupe politique est notifiée à la
présidence nombre de votants 345 car
nombre de suffrages exprimés 339 pour
l'adoption 114 contre 225 le sénat n'a
pas adopté
alors sur sur le 103 suis aussi une
demande de scrutin public par la
commission mais je voulais juste savoir
comme il y avait le même avis en fait de
la commission du gouvernement parce
qu'il était très proche est ce qu'on
considère que c'est le même vote
personne ne s'oppose à sa donc ces mêmes
votes donc sur le 103 alors ensuite ça
ce n'est pas un public voilà alors même
question pour les amendements identiques
619 et 640 donc qui ont eu un avis donc
défavorable de la commission favorable
du gouvernement est ce qu'on peut
considérer aussi que c'est le même vote
tout le monde est d'accord ok donc même
vote donc ensuite c'est l'amendement 526
qui a eu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée et
l'amendement 527 qui était un avis
favorable de la commission est
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
ses contres qui s'abstient il est
affecté il est adopté donc l' art
et donc sauver donc l'article 21 est
bien rétabli
avec cet amendement avec la rédaction de
l'amendement donc 527
donc après l'article 21
l'amendement 500 le sur allier merci
madame la présidente monsieur me lisent
mes chers collègues notre droit doit
toujours permettre la liberté
d'enseignement je me réjouis donc que
nous ayons rejeté l'interdiction de
l'instruction en famille à l'article 21
voulue par le gouvernement et soutenu
par la gauche en france instruction en
famille à distance aussi appelé conte à
la maison est déjà encadrée par le code
de l'éducation
tous les ans m l'inspection académique
vérifie le respect du droit à l'enfant à
l'instruction et évalue l'acquisition
progressive du socle commun de
connaissances tous les deux ans les
familles en tout cas celles qui ne sont
pas dans les zones de non france finance
contrôlée par là mais par la mairie sur
les raisons qui les poussent à ce mode
d'instruction les contrôles existent et
ils peuvent empêcher les dérives
islamistes mais la réalité c'est que 98%
des cas et conclut que l'instruction en
famille est satisfaisante malgré vos
affirmations monsieur le ministre ce
texte et se trompe de cible
d'ailleurs à ma connaissance aucun
terroriste ni même prêcheur radical né
le produit de l'école à la maison
68 enfants bénéficient aujourd'hui de ce
mode d'instruction parmi eux 20 il
suivait les cours réglementé du centre
national d'enseignement à distance la
première des raisons du choix de
l'instruction en famille n'est pas de se
séparer monsieur le ministre mais de
sauver son enfant de la déliquescence de
l'école publique détruite par
l'idéologie et le nivellement par le bas
mais aussi le handicap une activité
sportive ou artistique de haut niveau
l'éloignement géographique de
l'établissement mais aussi le
harcèlement et la phobie scolaire pour
tous ces enfants il convenait donc de
laisser à leurs parents le libre choix
de l'instruction en famille les
chercheurs professionnels de la santé
historien et pédagogue sont tous du même
avis il faut dépasser les amalgames et
les préjugés du gouvernement
l'instruction en famille d'un niveau
exigeant très exigeants l'éducation
nationale n'admettant pas que l'on
vienne contester son monopole dans la
production industrielle d'échec scolaire
conforter le respect des droits
fondamentaux les enfants de la diversité
de la pleine liberté éducative c'est
aussi protéger notre état de droit
cependant pour des questions évidentes
de souveraineté et de contrôler le
présenter en donnant trop
rendre obligatoire la localisation en
france des sièges sociaux des organismes
privés d'enseignement à distance
cette disposition contraignante a pour
objectif d'empêcher les influences
étrangères dans l'instruction des
enfants et d'éviter un enseignement à
distance de prêter le flanc à la
méfiance face à de potentiels excès
c'est pourquoi je vous invite à voter
cet amendement de vigilance pour une
meilleure liberté d'enseignement
merci la vie la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la présidente
peut-être une petite précision en
préambule sur sur l'article 21 noms
n'avons pas rétabli évidemment
l'intégralité de l'article 21 le vote
précédent a permis de valider et d'
approuver l'amendement déposé par madame
assassi sur la formation des inspecteurs
qui sont chargés de d'effectuer les
contrôles dans les familles telles que
ça a été défini dans cette dans cet
amendement
soyons ferions bien sûr que nous avons
conservé la suppression de l'article 21
tels que ça a été adopté en commission a
porté cette petite précision avant de
donner donc la vie sur la moment
l'amendement 502 de monsieur ravier qui
nous propose en fait un dispositif qui
est inopérant puisque le fait d'avoir le
siège social en france
n'empêche pas d'avoir des contenus
produits à l'étranger et en août cet
amendement serait contraire tout
simplement au droit de l'union
européenne sur la liberté
d'établissement
à ce titre la commission vous propose un
avis défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre mais ma vie alors je mets au
voile un moment donc 500 qui a reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté a et
je suis saisi d'un amendement 641
présentées par le groupe
moment sur le mini jeux vous allez
peut-être le retirer peut-être c'est à
vous oui oui mon amendement de
remerciement à la présidente présentait
messieurs les sénateurs il s'agit d'un
amendement de suppression dans la
logique de ce que je disais à monsieur
le rapporteur tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que dans la mesure où évidemment ce
que je souhaite c'est le maintien de
l'ancien article 21 et son régime
d'autorisation même si je salue le fait
que vous cherchez à reprendre les points
que vous considérez positif dans
l'éventuelle ex article 21
je considère qu évidemment précisément
cet article 21 défend dans sa version
initiale
cet enjeu donc c'est pour cette raison
que je propose cet amendement de
suppression avis de la commission
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je note que nous avons une
série d'amendements du gouvernement qui
vont dans le sens d'un rétablissement de
l'article 21 tels qu'ils étaient
proposés à l'assemblée nationale donc
celui ci en fait partie
c'était dispositions relatives à l'accès
des familles instruisant en famille un
accès aux services publics du numérique
éducatif à la validation des acquis
professionnels alors je m'interroge
quand même en termes de cohérence
étant donné que nous avons conservé la
suppression de l'article 21 que cet
article 21 bis à que j'ai moi même
proposé enquête adopté en commission
reprenait en fait une partie de
l'article 21 initial que vous souhaitiez
conserver me semble-t-il
je comprends pas bien la logique du coup
du raisonnement en dix ans la science
supprime le 21 bis on supprime une
nouvelle fois les dispositions que vous
souhaitiez validé dans l'article 21
donc bon je serai peut-être vous
entendre sur cette logique là en tout
cas pour les raisons que j'ai évoquées
c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission et monsieur le ministre c'est
la raison pour laquelle je vous demander
si vous retiriez en fait cet amendement
finalement devient incohérent
non vous le laisser
merci présentement je me considère pas
comme un cohérent malgré la puissance de
conviction du rapporteur leu leu ce que
j'ai voulu dire à fois par cet
amendement et parce que j'ai dit
précédemment c'était que l'article 21
une cohérence d'ensemble et je ne veux
pas le voir revenir en pièces détachées
sur tout cas pas toutes les pièces
détachées voilà donc c'est pourquoi il
ya cet amendement de suppression
monsieur auzias vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
culture républicaine g par principe la
vocation de faire confiance aux
fonctionnaires à tous les fonctionnaires
et quand le directeur général de
l'enseignement scolaire vient au sénat
en audition nous expliquer que
l'enseignement et femmes en famille est
passé de 0 1% à 0 5% et que la moitié
la moitié de ces prête de cette
augmentation est due à des raisons
religieuses
je fais confiance au directeur général
de l'enseignement scolaire c'est
peut-être de la naïveté mais c'est ma
naïveté républicaine et je le vis bien
comme ça
ce que je trouve insensé cher que l'ex
et que vous avez été inflexibles
irréductibles incorruptibles pour
défendre la république dans son
expression vestimentaire ect et textiles
et que là quand on est au coeur au coeur
du dispositif de la nation et que des
familles volontairement pour des
critères religieux refusent
l'instruction nationale parce qu'elle
est national vous ne voulez pas le voir
je ne comprends pas votre attitude
je continuerai et nous continuerons ici
à défendre ferdinand buisson et vous me
permettrait de finir mon intervention
par des mots de nouveau monsieur
grosperrin
nous sommes pour l'école buissonnière
l'école du buisson voilà donc ferdinand
buisson
je le cite une nouvelle fois tout
français est libre d'enseigner mais tous
français et tenu de prouver devant les
mêmes jugé de la même manière qu'il est
capable d'enseigner
français libres dans ces signé mais il
n'est pas libre de réclamer pour son
enseignement le privilège d'être
clandestins d'échapper à tous les
regards de produire tel résultat que bon
lui semble et de se refuser à les
laisser constaté dans les formes que
fixent la loi elle-même tout français
libres d'enseigner mais à la condition
de ne pas s'être volontairement placé
dans une condition qui le frappe
d'incapacité merci mal présidente
merci monsieur brisson oui mais c'est la
présidente
shapiro zodiac le ministre vient nous
tire lui même qui n'étaient pas capables
d'appréhender le nombre de personnes qui
de temps en forme qui sont à destruction
familles qui sont concernées par le
séparatisme c'est le ministre lui-même
qui nous dit quand je pense que dgesco
ce jour là à faire une balade et son
imagination mais en tous les cas je dois
je croire à la parole du ministre
puisqu'il nous a dit qu'il ne pouvait
pas appréhendé après madame la
présidente
le ministre est dans la cohérence il est
dans la cohérence du discours des
mureaux qui va le conduire à déposer si
cet amendement de suppression du travail
de contrôle que nous avons fait quand
nous sont proposés au contrôle de
l'instruction en famille nous sommes
d'ailleurs dans le prolongement de ce
nom ont fait sur l'école de la confiance
mais le ministre est bien dans cette
logique de suppression de l'instruction
famille qui était au coeur du discours
du président de la république aux
mureaux alors entre le discours du
bureau et aujourd'hui il ya eu le
conseil d'état qui vous a fait reculer
il ya lui l'assemblée nationale qui vous
a fait reculer y compris une partie de
la majorité présidentielle au sein de
cette assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui le juste le sénat continue
de porter ce que vous avez fustigé d'une
mère avec pas mal de détails sur le
combat mené par des parents qui s'étonne
ainsi d'être montrés du doigts d'être
soumis à suspicion d'être parfois même
humilié mais c'est ce combat qui vous a
fait reculer c'est pas votre intuition
première en contradiction totale avec ce
coup disait renan vous était bien dans
la nuit
gic du lisco numéro présente du
président de la république qui lui a
bien parlé de mettre fin à l'instruction
à domicile vous reculez mais l'essayer
pas de transformer ce recul en victoire
d'où vous en empêcher merci madame
installe brigneau moi je voudrais juste
hâte revenir quelques secondes parce que
monsieur mini vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de courage il fallait du courage
je pense que la semaine dernière le
courage le sait n'a eu le courage que
vous n'avez pas eu dans cette loi le
sénat il a eu le courage de pointer là
où il y avait du séparatisme ce que vous
n'aviez pas fait dans cette loi et le
courage aujourd'hui
et bien c'est d'aller chercher ses
enfants qui sont entre les mains
d'islamistes qui les isole de la société
alors le courage c'est d'aller les
chercher et de ne pas pénaliser les
autres voilà monsieur mise que je vous
faire dans cette loi et je pense que le
sénat a eu le courage que probablement
que la demande n'a pas eu mais madame
robert petit madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je ne suis pas certaine que certains
discours caricaturaux servent notre
assemblée
parce que pas un moment cet article 21
ans loos est interdite d'instruction
famille est là où on a eu un peu de
flottement c'est que finalement qu'est
ce que vous allez faire qu'est ce que
vous allez faire avec les articles qui
arrive c'est que vous allez renforcer ce
régime déclaratif en reprenant des
obligations qui sont prévus dans le
régime d'autorisation mais sans le dire
d'une façon que je pourrais même
qualifié peut-être d'hypocrites c'est à
dire qu'à un moment vous allez le durcir
ce régime déclarations on va le voir en
vous approchant quand même du régime
d'autorisation d'ailleurs on va vous
aider par un amendement parce qu'on va
compléter le régime en permettant par
certaines dispositions que finalement
vous soyez dans dans la même
configuration
alors pourquoi n'allez-vous pas jusqu'au
bout de la démarche
parce que c'est là que partent on vous
avait dit que le ministre on ne le
sentais pas à l'aise sur le sujet c'est
vous qu'on ne sont pas à l'aise sur le
sujet parce que dans certains cas et
notamment la semaine dernière eh bien
vous faites preuve de durcissement et on
va le voir d'ailleurs dans le cas des
universités ou dans d'autres
dispositions
et puis dans d'autres cas vous faites
preuve de beaucoup plus d'indulgence
voire même de tolérance
alors je crois que là il ya une
contradiction qu'il va falloir lever et
qui en tout cas là aussi ne vous
permettent pas en tout cas d'affirmer
d'affirmer que cet article inter étaient
là pour supprimer la section famille je
pense qu'il ne faut pas vraiment
caricaturer les différents articles de
ce projet de loi ainsi même gatel
imagine la présidente moi je veux bien
qu'on emploie le mot caricaturé mais je
suis en profond désaccord avec ça il n'y
a pas de caricature et il n'y a pas de
position peu claire de ce qui
aujourd'hui disent hominis nous
partageons votre objectif
nous sommes conscients comme vous qu'il
y à un danger maintenant le moyen que
vous utilisez ne nous semble pas le bon
ce que l'acquisition est laisse à mes
chers collègues on peut faire de
l'argutie tout l'après midi
y at il une liberté constitutionnelle
sur le choix du mode d'enseignement
on doit répondre par oui ou non cette
liberté constitutionnelle elle s'impose
que l'on eût préféré que tous les
enfants aillent à l'école publique ou
pas dès lors qu'il ya une liberté
constitutionnelle qui était dite et
redite par le conseil d'état on ne peut
pas glisser sur un champ de déclarations
de d'autorisation qui peut nous faire
plaisir mais qui en plus ne résout pas
la question parce qu'encore une fois moi
je vous mets au défi les uns et les
autres de trouver un seul malveillants
qui flottera dans le son dossier
d'autorisation
c'est dans le contrôle et le
renforcement du contrôle qu'il la
réponse est c'est la seule réponse est
que il me semble que nous avons
travaillé sur l'école privée hors
contrat nous avons maintenu le principe
de déclaration mais renforcé l'exigence
mettre plus d'exigences année ni être
hypocrite n'y est caricatural ne nous
faisons pas de procès d'intention
il y à issy de regard de lecture sur des
libertés constitutionnelles
merci alors je mets aux voix
l'amendement à monsieur rapporte
nationale président juste quelques mots
pour dire moi aussi que je ne peux pas
accepter qu'on nous qualifie d'
hypocrites sur ceux sur le traitement de
cette de ce texte est particulièrement
sur l'article 21 il y avait une solution
assez binaire assez simple qui aurait
consisté purement et suppléments et
simplement à rejeter à supprimer
l'article 21 et on passait à la suite ça
serait sans doute été une attitude
caricatural nous avons souhaité faire de
la dentelle
parce que nous sommes convaincus qu'il
fallait conserver cette liberté du droit
au recours à l'instruction en famille et
que néanmoins nous acceptions de mettre
sur la table le traitement de de la
modernisation du cadre du recours à la f
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure ça
n'était pas acquis d'avancé
nous avons eu ce courage seul le
ministre de le faire nous n'avons pas
rejeter en bloc le sujet nous avons dit
en parlant du sujet puisqu'on nous le
met sur la table
en revanche on fait de la dentelle et on
va chercher les enfants aux radars par
exemple on renforce les contrôles pour
voir véritablement aussi les familles
qui pratique qui détournent les f à
d'autres fins si on peut aller les
trouver autrement qu'en remplissant un
document administratif d'autorisation
que les rectorats aurait eu à traiter
merci alors je mets aux voix
l'amendement 641 du gouvernement qui a
aussi un avis défavorable de la
commission qui est pour
qui est contre
qui ça siens il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 192 monsieur brisson
cet amendement est une illustration de
ce que nous venons de dire et c'est une
réponse à ceux qui nous accusent de
caricaturer nous refusons le contrôle a
priori parce qu'il entraîne de la
suspicion et le régime d'autorisations
c'est un régime ne contrôle a priori que
nous refusons c'est pas des caricatures
ça me semble au contraire
fondée en tout cas nous sommes en
cohérence avec nous mêmes mais nous
acceptons aussi un contrôle et par
exemple et amendements proposent que la
déclaration destruction domicile à la
rentrée se fasse dans un délai de 8
jours un délai exister en cas de
changement d'un enfants déscolarisés en
cours d'année en cas de changement de
résidence
rien n'était indiquée sur la déclaration
a pas que celle ci se faisait à la
rentrée nous mettons un délai nous
travaillons le texte dans un sens de
contrôle d'autres l'objectif en nous
donnant les moyens de se contrôler mais
savoir peu après avoir posé fermement
notre volonté de préserver la liberté et
de bien marquer que nous rejetons
profondément to control seat a priori
avec sa patte de suspicion sur les
familles et 7 déduit jouer d'autant plus
important que nous proposons
parallèlement une sanction en cas de non
déclaration
voilà pourquoi il nous semble qu'il ne
peut pas y avoir de sanction sur un
délai si le délai ne se trouve pas dans
le texte
je pense que le cdh a donc travaillent
de manière très fine sur ce texte sur ce
simple principe nous nous refusons le
contrôle a priori nous sommes pour un
contrôle a posteriori
parce que nous pensons qu'une liberté ne
s'exerce pas aux demandeurs
d'autorisation est exact
dans le cas de la loi et dans le cadre
du contrôle des autorités à partir de
cette loi merci l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
comme l'a dit mon collègue max brisson
ce amendement permet de clarifier les
obligations de déclaration des femmes et
il existait dans le code de l'éducation
le délaisse le délai de huit jours en
cas d'un changement c'est un
déménagement modification des modalités
d'inscription il y avait un flou
concernant les enfants instruits
plusieurs en famille plusieurs années de
suite c'est un cas sur deux en fait à
peu près un enfant sur deux ne le fait
moins d'un an donc le code prévoit ce
prévoyaient seulement une déclaration
annuelle désormais avec cet amendement
la déclaration aura lieu à date fixe en
cas de renouvellement d'instruction en
famille au plus tard huit jours après la
rentrée
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission a émis un avis favorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
merci mais la présidente plusieurs
plusieurs romans donc d'abord pour
réitérer le fait que cette série
d'amendements proposés en effet on peut
les prendre comme une validation de la
première version de l'article 21 c'est
bien le signal que il y a quelque chose
à régler et dans tout le débat qui a
précédé tout à l'heure quand on disait
vous tapez à côté vous faites quelque
chose qui a rien à voir avec le réel
bien d'une certaine façon vous êtes en
train de dire le contraire maintenant et
tant mieux d'ailleurs puisque vous dites
bien que cet article un t1 pointer les
choses justes et donc le débat ne porte
que sur la question autorisation
déclarations et il n'est pas exact dire
comme plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont dit
que autorisation est synonyme de
contradiction avec la liberté et
déclaration serait le signe de la
liberté ce n'est pas exact c'est plutôt
le signe d'un refus d'un sujet est
minime ou d'un sujet maxime c'est à dire
si vous prenez le droit de propriété et
personne ne va dire ici le droit de
propriété c'est pas important
c'est dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme largement avant que la liberté
d'enseignement soient consacrés et bien
quand vous construisez quelque chose six
minimes vous ferait une déclaration si
c'est maxime vous demander une
autorisation
est ce que ce n'est pas de la plus haute
importance l'instruction d'un enfant et
est-ce que c'est pas important de
s'assurer à priori que ces droits ne
vont pas être bafoués plutôt que de le
constater a posteriori c'est cela le
débat en fait et donc sur chacun des
points on ne va pas être en désaccord
sur les modalités puisque c'est une
sorte d'hommage ne dirais pas du vice à
la vertu mais en tout cas grand hommage
qui est rendu à l'article posthuma
l'article 21 provisoirement posthume et
bien ainsi soit-il je suis d'accord avec
l'hommage qui est ainsi rendue mais je
veux qu'ils soient rendues dans le cadre
complet de la logique de l'article 21
c'est à dire un régime d'autorisation
qui défend les droits de l'enfant
peut-être est-ce là le point nodal sur
lequel nous sommes qui permet d'épurer
les faux débats sur va-t-on supprimer ou
pas l'instruction en famille mais en
tout cas c'est la raison de mon avis
défavorable sur cet amendement non pas
parce que y'a pas un sujet mais parce
que ce sujet est mieux traité dans le
cadre de l'autorisation enfin pour
rentrer dans le détail si on vous suit
veille complètement en réalité ce que ce
qui est proposé la conduirait à avoir
cette exigence uniquement vis-à-vis des
familles qui pratiquent l'instruction en
famille alors que dans l'état du droit
nous avons cette exigence globale
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des familles
donc cela fait un bouquet de raisons
pour donner un avis défavorable
merci monsieur souliès merci la
présidente monsieur le ministre je
partage complètement l'analyse c'est à
dire que vous êtes en train de réécrire
tout le dispositif en le plaçant à
posteriori vous êtes en train de créer
un régime d'autorisations à posteriori
et quand on regarde les deux régimes
qu'est ce qui le différencie une chose
qui est essentiel à mes yeux c'est que
le régime d'autorisation demandé par le
gouvernement permet à l'administration
de l'éducation nationale d'avoir un
premier contact avec la famille ce qui
est quand on est mieux qu'une lettre
déposée dans la boîte et je trouve que
en bon républicain que je suis à voir à
un moment donné de l'instruction du
dossier une relation entre la famille et
l'éducation nationale qui représente et
qui défend les droits de l'enfant à
l'instruction ça ne le sent pas
ni anti constitutionnelle ni abusé de la
liberté d'enseignement la différence
entre nos deux systèmes reconnaissait le
elle est juste là cette possibilité est
donnée d'administration de discuter avec
la famille de son projet pédagogique et
moi ça me semble tout à fait essentiel
merci ma la présidente monsieur magny
effectivement on assiste là à un débat
qui aurait dû être tranché par la
suppression de l'article 21 et qui est
un défi il revient puisque en europe est
à peu près tout ce qui était conduit
l'article 21 ans a déjà été dit je ne
vais pas revenir là dessus mais c'est
quand même un peu étonnant de voir si un
peu le même débat que nous avions eue
sur la loi concernant les établissements
privés hors contrat
on refuse d'aller vers un régime
d'autorisation on nous dit qu'il faut de
la liberté et ensuite on vient dans des
détails apporter des amendements qui
vont compliquer encore plus
considérablement que l'était le régime
d'autorisation préalable un régime qui
n'est que de que dents définitives que
de dérogation qui aurait pu être à
apporter à des situations particulières
et qui ne va pas dans le cas général
moi je suis assez étonné de cette de
cette méthode
et il ya un certain nombre d'articles
effectivement que nous pourrons voter
parce que ces amendements correspondent
à des nécessités de faire évoluer le
dispositif qui n'est pas d'autorisation
mais qui est effectivement un postérieur
à la décision de faire de l'instruction
à domicile mais à mon avis ce n'est pas
ça qui va modifier beaucoup l'intention
première qui était de protéger
effectivement les enfants qui sont dans
ce système d'instruction à domicile
merci monsieur brisson
quitte à nous répéter mais puisque
chacun se répète vous avez votre
cohérence souffrirait que nous ayons la
note
nous restons en régime de déclaration là
vous voulez passer en régime
d'autorisation jeu parce que le vote a
tranché chacun est dans sa logique dans
sa cohérence et la maintiendra
certainement jusque tard dans la nuit
nous refusons donc le régime
d'autorisation pour le reste nous sommes
aussi dans une logique de contrôle parce
que nous sommes responsables
et quand on se souvient de dire monsieur
le ministre il y a dans le texte du
projet de loi une sanction particulière
en cas de non déclaration destruction à
domicile qui ne portent pas donc sur
l'ensemble des élèves et donc dans ce
cadre là nous pensons qu'il est de bonne
politique de fixer un délai précis de
manière à ne pas avoir d'ambiguïté
lorsque faute de déclaration au delà du
délai prévu s'appliqueront les sanctions
qui sont prévus dans le texte
merci monsieur le président la faune
juste intervenir parce que finalement il
ya une série d'amendements qui porte un
peu sur le même débat entre la moi je
précisais tout à l'heure et c'était
quelque chose qui était très présent
dans la commission nous ne faisons pas
preuve de naïveté par rapport aux
dérives que vous dénoncez que vous avez
identifié
nous partageons l'inquiétude du
dévoiement de l'instruction en famille
par quelques familles qui l'ont utilisée
à des fins qui ne sont pas celles que
nous souhaitons c'est donc pour ça qu'on
a rajouté un certain nombre de verrous
de cliquer afin de mieux identifier ces
familles et de mieux contrôler ces
familles sans remettre en cause et c'est
là où je pense nous avons une différence
avec certains dans cet hémicycle
sans remettre en cause le bien fondé de
la structure en famille pour un certain
nombre de familles pour lequel ça
correspond à quelque chose dans le temps
de l'enfant dans l'éducation de l'enfant
et dans l'instruction de l'enfant donc
nous sommes dans l'esprit de ce que vous
cherchez c'est à dire rendre le
dispositif de l'instruction en famille
plus efficace en en augmentant les
identifications des familles
malveillantes comme dit françoise gatel
et en renforçant les contrôles et c'est
pour ça que je pense que in fine et
notre système celui auquel nous
aboutirons je l'espère à l'issue de ce
débat sera plus efficace par rapport à
votre objectif initial à savoir de
lutter contre l'intégrisme
sans remettre en cause ce qui est
quelque chose pour nous d'importants la
liberté n'ont pas la liberté pour nous
et on oublie de dire à chaque fois la
liberté pour les familles
le fait de pouvoir choisir entre les
trois modes d'instruction le fait que
les familles puissent choisir librement
et à partir du moment notre peut-être
une différence fondamentale là dessus
mais à partir du moment où il ya une
autorisation
ce n'est plus une liberté le mot liberté
ne correspond pas aux motorisations donc
à partir du moment où on met une
autorisation ce n'est plus la liberté et
pour nous c'est important d'assurer et
d'assumer cette liberté tout en veillant
à l'objectif qui est le vôtre de lutter
contre les familles utilisent de façon
malveillante cette liberté merci alors
je vais mettre aux voix l'amendement 192
qui a reçu un avis favorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour et qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est donc adopté
l'amendement 477 de même de la
présidente c'est à vous merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
l'école doit être un de nos principaux
champs de bataille comme l'a révélé
notre commission d' enquête sur la
radicalisation islamiste
personne ne peut le nier l'école joue un
rôle majeur dans la construction de
notre nation elle transmet non seulement
des savoirs mais aussi des valeurs des
principes elle modèle les esprits notre
plus jeune génération il doit donc en
retour une protection sans faille
c'est donc regrettable que notre école
publique et nos établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et été mis de
côté dans ce texte
vous avez souhaité pointer
l'enseignement à domicile sans traiter
le fond du problème
les petits fantômes de la république
certes l'instruction à domicile est en
forte augmentation
mais cela ne représente que 0,5 pour
cent des élèves français soit 62 mille
enfants vous me répondrez qu'aucun
enfant de la république ne doit être
sacrifié oui mais monsieur le ministre
lorsque notre dispositif de contrôle de
suivi et d'identification présente
autant de trous dans la raquette
il convient de cette les allées colmatée
et non de déclarer forfait lors des
débats au sénat sur la loi pour une
école de la confiance en mai 2010 neuf
j'ai défendu de nombreux amendements
visant à renforcer l'opérationnalité de
l'encadrement de l'instruction en
famille souvenez-vous avec notamment la
généralisation du numéro ian e mais dans
ce cadre plus apaisée ils ont été
balayés d'un revers de la main il n'y
avait à l'époque pas de sujet pas de
débat je saisis donc cette nouvelle
occasion pour vous présenter des
amendements pragmatique inspiré de
nombreuses auditions que j'ai pu mener
auprès d'élus auprèsde inspecteur
académique et de familles ayant fait ce
choix pour respecter les équilibres
fragiles
introduit par la loi de jules ferry de
1882 ce premier amendement propose donc
et vous nous demandiez tout à l'heure de
vous proposer des solutions c'est ce que
je fais ce premier amendement propose
donc d'insister si tu es un régime de
déclaration sous motif poli f
ce régime intermédiaire éviterait de
restreindre excessivement cette liberté
contrairement au régime d'autorisation
supprimée en commission
cette alternative permettrait également
d'inviter ces familles à formaliser
démarche pédagogique en la motivant en
mairie comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
lorsqu'une association souhaite
organiser une manifestation je vous
invite donc à soutenir cet homme en ont
mesuré et proportionnée chers collègues
merci merci la vie la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
sinon la présidente mme smith chers
collègues
or c'était une position de la commission
qui va permettre de répondre aux
interrogations des uns et des autres
qu'on a pu entendre sur notre volonté
notre la suspicion de rétablir l'article
21 tel qu'il était il nous a été proposé
depuis l'assemblée nationale puisque cet
amendement restera en fait les
possibilités de recours à l'instruction
à famille via les quatre critères qui
sont à nouveau évoqué dans cet
amendement les modalités pratiques de
mise en place s'interrogent dans le
cadre du maintien que nous souhaitons au
sein du système de déclaration le
dispositif qui proposait qui semble peu
opérant je note par ailleurs une une
incohérence si je peux me permettre
sharks l'incohérence rédactionnelle
puisque une déclaration ne peut pas être
accordé
on voit qu'il ya d'ailleurs peut-être le
motorisation qui se cache presque
derrière cet amendement donc c'est un
avis défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre mais ma vie alors je vais
mettre aux voix l'anc l'amendement 477
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui ça ce n est pas adopté
l'amendement 253 mais la présidente
billon merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 21 bis à prévoit une
validation des acquis de compétences
pour les personnes dispensant une
instruction en famille durant au moins
deux années complètes
durant nos différents travaux sur ce
texte de nombreux trous dans la raquette
sont apparus notamment concernant les
obligations des contrôles effectués par
l'autorité de l'état compétente en
matière d'éducation des personnes en
charge de l'instruction en famille
comment le dispositif pourra être mis en
place de manière satisfaisante alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous observons déjà des
difficultés dans les contrôles qu'elle
sera la grille d'évaluation et de
validation pour les personnes éligibles
à ce dispositif les validations seront
elles automatique
au bout de deux années d'instruction en
famille les parents éligibles de vente
il présentait un projet pédagogique
précis et complet cette mesure paraît en
décalage avec l'esprit du reste du texte
d'un côté vous souhaitez favoriser le
plus possible une instruction au sein
des établissements scolaires et de
l'autre vous voulez rendre quasi
automatique la validation des acquis
pour les parents assurant cette
instruction en famille je ne compte pas
je ne comprends pas tout à fait la
logique ici dans ce cas précis les
garde-fous proposé encadrant le
dispositif de la validation des acquis
de compétences paraissent minces c'est
pourquoi je vous propose de supprimer ce
dernier merci merci l'avis de la
commission sur le reporter si madame la
présidente alors quelques mots sur la
validation d'acquis d'expérience
professionnelle qui est courant dans de
nombreux secteurs institué par la loi de
modernisation sociale du 17 janvier 2002
ça constitue à côté de la formation
initiale et de la formation continue une
troisième voie d'accès à la
certification professionnelle
c'est un outil d'insertion donc à ce
type d'insertion professionnelle en 2019
ça concernait environ 55 mille candidats
qui ont déposé un dossier de 2 recevait
recevabilité en vue d'obtenir la vae par
la vae un diplôme ou un titre de livre
et par l'état depuis 2002 toute personne
peut obtenir la totalité d'une
certification grâce à à la
reconnaissance de son expérience que
cette dernière était acquise à travers d
activité salariée non salariée ou
bénévole
d'ailleurs la valeur est présente dans
de très nombreux ministères le travail
la défense l'agriculture enseignement
supérieur l'éducation nationale la
culture et jeunesse la santé les
affaires sociales ou encore l'écologie
dire à quel point c'est vaste s'agissant
de cet article en particulier les
conditions de validation des compétences
sont encadrés puisqu'il faudra au moins
deux années complètes d'instruction en
famille
or ça a été dit à nombreuses de
nombreuses reprises environ une famille
sur deux de la pratique que pendant une
année
par ailleurs elle n'est pas automatique
bien sûr il faut déposer un dossier
actuellement le taux de certification
des dossiers présentés tous ministères
confondus est de l'ordre de un petit peu
plus de 60% donc
la vie ne donnera pas à ce titre-là
droit à être enseignant bien évidemment
c'est pas un concours d'entrée dans la
fonction publique les conditions pour
enseigner y compris d'ailleurs dans les
établissements privés hors contrat 100
ans encadrés par des conditions de
diplôme strictes enfin selon le sondage
réalisé par le collectif de familles en
effe félicia se sont madame la
présidente dé ce sont les femmes qui à
91 7 % assurent l'instruction en famille
la mise en place de navettes permettrait
donc de reconnaître les compétences
acquises dans l'instruction de leurs
enfants afin de faciliter l'insertion
professionnelle des femmes
je suis persuadé que vous y serez
sensible c'est la raison pour laquelle
je la commission émet un avis
défavorable à votre amendement merci la
vie du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci marc président dont je suis
d'accord avec les arguments de même à
sénatrice billon donc j'ai un avis
favorable
merci monsieur manille oui la présidente
sioniste nous voterons nous est cet
amendement parce que alors là cet
article il va il dépasse tout ça veut
dire que non seulement on ne contrôle
plus en autorise plus préalablement
l'instruction en famille mais en plus on
lui donne une prime en donnant une vae à
celui ou celle qui la réalisera pendant
au moins deux ans c'est à dire que celui
ou celle qui voulait faire pendant une
année
si envie d'avoir une vue il faut qu'il
le fasse une deuxième année donc il
écarte son enfant encore plus longtemps
de l'école primaire de l'école les notes
de l'école secondaire ou n'importe
quelle classe avec elle et l'enfant
devrait être moi je trouve quand même
que c'est un petit peu clientéliste je
dirais merci monsieur brisson
voilà peut-être à nouveau cette semaine
beaucoup de parents se rendus compte que
faire l'école à la maison c'était bien
difficile et ça nécessitait beaucoup
d'investissements chez en général plutôt
souvent d'accord avec un aiguillon mais
pas cette fois parce que je trouve que
ce travail qui mobilise beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup d'investissements
rentre parfaitement dans ce qu'on peut
appeler la valorisation des acquis de
l'expérience et la deuxième raison pour
laquelle je suis d'accord avec le
rapporteur
je ne voterai pas l'amendement danic bio
c'est que ce texte depuis plusieurs mois
il envoie quand même un message sur ces
familles particulièrement humiliant et
fait de beaucoup de suspicion c'est la
seule ligne qui donne un peu de
valorisation à ceux qui font ce choix a
pas tellement on est favorable ce choix
ce qui est le cas ma chère collègue
parce qu'il faut être cohérent avec
nous-mêmes et accepter que ce travail
que cet investissement et de joie
puis-je dans le cas d'une certification
extrêmement balisé puisse en effet être
reconnu je pense qu au tarot serait
cohérent avec notre volonté de maintenir
la liberté de choix des parents
l'instruction à domicile et de valoriser
le travail qui est fait et cela n'a plus
rien à voir avec l'entrée dans
l'enseignement aussi bien dans les
établissements privés sous contrat que
dans l'enseignement public puisque là il
s'agit bien de concours qui sont
parfaitement délimités merci madame
gatel merci madame la présidente
monsieur miss mes chers collègues je
voterai l'amendement de ma collègue
annick billon parce que je considère que
la validation des acquis des compétences
dans ce contexte pardonnez-moi chevaux
il n'est pas provocateur c'est une
fantaisie que je ne comprends pas
aujourd'hui nous parlons de la liberté
constitutionnelle qui permet à des
familles d'instruire leurs enfants et la
plupart le font bien moi je n'ai pas de
problèmes d'ordre juridique sur ce sujet
maintenant ça a été rappelé par le
rapporteur
il ya possibilité pour toute personne
qui le souhaite de faire valider des
acquis de l'expérience on le voit
parfois pour des élus
qu'il faut aussi valider leurs acquis
mais là nous sommes je pense dans une
autre dimension et que rien n'interdit
un parent qui auraient pratiqué
l'enseignement dans sa famille avec des
méthodes particulières très adapté aux
enfants de se présenter à des
validations d'acquis mais pourquoi
inscrits on dans le texte
j'avoue que je ne comprends pas bien
cette idée donc encore une fois je
voterai l'amendement de notre collègue
yannick billon alors je vais mettre aux
voix l'amendement 253 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et un avis
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est donc adoptée et je
mets aux voix l'article 21 10 à qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient et
donc adopté après l'article 21 10 à
l'amendement 209 madame la présidente de
la cre merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
comme je lé rappeler en présentant mon
précédent amendement le vrai problème
n'est pas l'instruction en famille mais
bien le contrôle et le suivi de cette
dernière
d'autres nombreuses familles m'ont
confié le fait qu'elles n'étaient pas
contrôlées annuellement que cela
dépendait grandement de la relation de
confiance de proximité parfois
restaurées avec leurs représentants
locaux où les inspecteurs académiques de
leur département
de plus nos mères ne sont pas préparés à
la conduite de ces enquêtes à domicile
aucune grille d'évaluation de leur ai
transmises
ce qui fait d'ailleurs l'objet de mon
amendement 207 que nous examinerons par
la suite de nombreux élus ne s'estime
pas en mesure de pénétrer au domicile de
leurs administrés pour juger si
l'environnement et propos est propice à
une instruction en famille ou non il
faut avouer que c'est plus que délicat
de plus à ce jour aucune transmission
d'information entre les contrôles opérés
par les élus locaux et ceux menés par
les inspecteurs académiques n'est prévu
or ils sont nombreux à le souhaiter
c'est sur ce sujet précis du contrôle
que nous devons concentrer tous nos
efforts pour qu'il n'existe plus aucun
enfant fantôme sur notre territoire pour
reprendre les termes d'un inspecteur
académique de mon département
les contrôles académiques sont un moyen
pour eux de prendre la température aux
fins de constater ou non les carences
éducatives et le cas échéant de les
déclarer
il faut donc s'assurer que le
thermomètre fonctionne correctement et
que suite au diagnostic le traitement
suive des inspecteurs académiques m'ont
confié que le constat d'un manquement
dans les acquis d'expérience attendu par
un enfant ne donne pas forcément lieu à
une action pour y remédier des mesures
doivent pourtant systématiquement être
prises une fois ce signalement effectué
l'objet cet amendement est donc de
clarifier un dispositif qui devrait être
évident à savoir la mise en place d'une
injonction d'inscription dans un
établissement public ou privé en cas de
défauts évidents dans les acquis
d'expérience attendue d'un
enfant en instruction en famille je vous
remercie merci la vie des communes sur
le sujet rapporteur c'est la présidence
amendement vise à mettre en place une
ruse scolarisation immédiate d'un enfant
de 14 ans ou plus si le premier contrôle
en famille a été déclarée insuffisant
sans attendre les résultats du deuxième
contrôle c'est un un traitement de
défaveur en quelque sorte qui est que
rien ne justifie pour une situation
particulière sur les enfants de 14 ans
et plus donc à ce titre c'est un avis
défavorable de la commission
merci l'avis du gouvernement mais ma vie
je mets donc aux voix l'amendement 209
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient donc
pas adopter le 212 la présidente de
nacre
merci présidente monsieur le ministre
nos élus locaux nos inspecteurs
académiques sont parfois confrontés à un
refus de certains parents de se
soumettre aux enquêtes du f pourtant
obligatoire or ces contrôles sont
indispensables il permet de vérifier
entre autres que les enfants effectuent
leur instruction dans de bonnes
conditions qu'ils ne font pas l'objet de
sévices psychologiques physiques ou
encore qu'ils reçoivent une instruction
adapté dans un environnement propice
l'objet de cet amendement est donc de
rendre systématique un dispositif déjà
existant le signalement au procureur de
la république de tours refus par un
parent de se soumettre à une enquête ou
de tout incident lié à ce contrôle en
mettant à profit cet outil c'est
apporter une solution aux problèmes que
vous aviez soulevé lors de votre
audition par la commission d' enquête
sur la radicalisation islamiste monsieur
le ministre vous aviez déploré le fait
qu'en 2010 9 72% de ses enfants étaient
convoqués et que seulement 63% avait été
effectivement contrôlés 37 % passent à
travers les mailles du filet et près de
10 % semble se soustraire à cette
enquête
7 interpellant vous évoquez un manque de
moyens humains et financiers mais c'est
l'opérationnalité de nos procédures qui
est pointé du doigt par les agents de
ces contrôles rendre automatique le
signalement au procureur de la
république serait un bon début je vous
remercie
merci l'avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur
présidente oui je comprends bien la
démarche de notre collègue nathalie
delattre
c'est un amendement qui en fait qui est
satisfait par le droit existant à double
titre
si je peux m'expliquer la circulaire sur
le déroulement de l'instruction en
famille d'abord circulaire de 2011 qui
prévoit déjà la saisine du procureur de
la république
en cas de refus de contrôle d'une part
et d'autre part l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale qui dispose que toute
autorité constituée tout officier public
ou fonctionnaire qui dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions acquiert la connaissance
d'un crime ou d'un délit est tenu d'en
donner avis sans délai au procureur de
la république et de transmettre à ce
magistrat tous les renseignements procès
verbaux et actes qui y sont relatifs cet
article s'applique dans le cas d'un
refus de contrôle puisqu'il s'agit d'un
délit donc cet amendement est doublement
satisfait si je puis dire donc c'est une
demande de retrait sinon un avis
défavorable de la commission
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur min mais
ma vie même est présidente
je leur tire mais il faudrait quand même
que des consignes soient passées pour
qu'il soit utilisé parce que encore une
fois il ya vraiment des failles c'est
vrai que c'est dommage mais ça me
permettait d' insister sur ces
manquements merci
[Musique]